No abandoned three,
two
and we're live.
What's up buddy?
Hey,
how are you?
I'm very sorry about that.
A sound of the thing in the background.
Ladies and gentlemen here.
That was wasn't.
That's annoying.
We'll shut that off.
Sure,
go ahead.
Okay.
Can you shut it off?
Jamie?
Um,
dad is because there was,
there was smoke in this room and the
Godfather has a,
uh,
an issue with the smoke.
How'd you get over your asthma?
Uh,
around puberty it often subsides,
especially if you're quite athletic,
which I was.
And then it completely went away by
about 13 and only came back by about 25,
but now I'm not full blown asthmatic.
Only when I get sick,
if I,
let's say,
get a cold,
it will migrate to my chest.
Turned into bronchitis.
And what will take you four days to
fight?
Might take me a month of whooping cough.
That's why I'm really careful about not
getting a quote.
You know,
you must be a hand washer.
Well,
that's why when I came out of the
bathroom,
my instinct was to tell Jamie as I was
shaking his hand,
I washed my hands because I'm always
careful about checking other people's
hands.
I'd like to extend them the same
courtesy.
Yeah,
man.
I shake some people's hands and it's
like they just dumped it in the pool.
It's some people like they get so sweaty
and you shake their hand.
You Go,
well,
okay,
but what's going on with his hand?
Like what kind of weird bacteria?
I read this article that was saying that
water bottles,
when you reuse water bottle,
they've tested them and they say that
there's less bacteria on dog toys.
It's pretty bad.
Well,
that's why by the way,
I've resorted to fist bumping because
I'm cool,
but it just reduces the amount of germ
transfer from one person to the other by
just going like this,
but don't you think that that
compromises your immune system by not
exposing it to a lot of different
things?
There is actually research on this right
from an illusionary medicine.
Kids who grow up in very sterile
environments end up suffering from
greater respiratory ailments,
precisely because their system hasn't
been kicked up.
Yeah,
I believe that.
I rarely get sick and I shake a lot of
hands,
but I know a lot of people that don't
and they're kind of sick all the time.
Like I don't want to get sick.
I'm like,
but maybe that's what's going on.
Maybe with French kiss later after the
other exciting.
Don't you threatened me with a good
time.
It's,
um,
I think it's also really important.
I don't know how much you partake of
this,
but uh,
to consume probiotics,
do you would eat acidophilus or yogurt
or yogurt?
I do like Kimchi.
I don't do it by design.
I think maybe just those preferences are
healthy and so I'm,
I'm happy to hear that they are good
probiotics and for grapplers in
particular,
grapplers are very,
um,
particular about the consumption of
probiotics because we get a lot of
ringworm and I'm also a staph infections
too.
There's a lot of different infections
that people can get from.
Especially ringworm,
know staph infections is really more for
an,
from an open cut.
But uh,
having healthy skin flora is very
important.
Why all
you kids listening don't use
antibiotics.
So it's not,
it's not the right way to go.
There's a lot of healthy soaps that are
used like tea tree oil and eucalyptus
that are really good for you that are
probiotic.
Right?
Keep the idea of warm and mind because
later I'd like to talk about brain worms
and how it relates to a condition that
is affecting the west.
We can get into it now or you mean like
Toxoplasma?
That'll be one.
There's other ones.
There are many others.
Do you want to get into that now?
Sure.
Okay.
So that's the polsky on.
I know know I should write to them
because it was amazing.
He is amazing.
I wrote to him a while ago,
maybe a year and a half or two years
ago,
but at the time he to come on my show.
Uh,
but he was very busy writing a few
books,
which I'm guessing he's probably done
with now.
Yeah.
Well he was busy then.
We had a meet him in La,
in his hotel room,
and we had to film.
We only had an hour.
He literally landed,
got into his hotel room.
We went with him as he opened up the
door to his hotel.
We sat down with them and it's just a
little table and chair there is
fantastic.
Yeah.
So basically I argued that in the same
way that there are all sorts of animals
that once they are infected with this
brain warm and they are different
instantiations of it,
uh,
they,
they become zombified,
right?
I mean,
just to give you another example,
the spider wasp will sting the spider,
which,
which is much bigger than it rendering
it.
Zombified then carries it into its
burrow,
lays its eggs on the invivo spider,
and then when the eggs hatch,
they eat it in Vivo.
And I argued that the,
the political correctness is akin to the
spider wasps sting because it's
zombifies us into walking quietly
through the abyss of infinite darkness a
while.
Horrible things are happening around us,
but why we think that we're doing the
right thing.
While we think that yet we know we're
not,
we're being not racist and good and
progressive,
uh,
but,
but to go back to the brain warm idea,
so I coined the term not to be cute,
but to actually name this collective
condition.
I called it ostrich per acidic syndrome.
Yeah.
We've talked about this before.
We talk about.
We know that that's a myth.
Well,
yeah,
yeah.
That the Boston.
Because it's become just a metaphor for
her.
Yeah,
absolutely.
The Myth being folks that ostriches
don't really stick their head in the
exactly.
Uh,
and,
and it's,
it's really taken on a life of its own.
At this point.
I'm actually thinking of studying this
scientifically,
not just as something that I talk about
in my public engagement.
What is it that causes some people to be
more likely to be arrested enticed by
the types of mindsets that would cause
you to suffer from ostrich parasitic
syndrome.
So a classic example would be,
which I guess we'll we'll get into
how much evidence do you need to see
around the world that there might be
some religious ideology that is somewhat
problematic and antithetical to secular
liberal modern values.
How much information or what is the type
of information that you would need to
see before you are able to arrive to
such a conclusion.
And so one
of the things I'm thinking of doing is
to formally quantify a score of ops,
how much somebody suffers from won't be
as,
as a type of mindset and what are some
predictors that could help us understand
who is more or less likely to be the
afflicted by this mindset?
Well,
there's certain people that just never
want to hurt anyone's feelings except
when they think that it is within their
rights to attack that person because
that person is somehow or another
victimizing someone else and then
there'll be far more egregious than the
original offense.
Did you know about that guy that in
Canada that's getting sued?
Well,
he,
the Human Rights Council find him
$12,000 because you walked into the
apartment that he owned with shoes on
because there was a Muslim family living
there.
Um,
their lease was up and he was looking to
rent the apartment.
They stopped responding to his texts and
so he opened up the apartment to show
this,
uh,
this apartment that he owns and because
he walked into a building that he owns
with his shoes on,
he has to pay them $12,000 for failing
to accommodate their religious practices
while showing their apartment to
perspective tenants.
That's crazy.
Welcome to Canada.
We just had a thing called the motion
and one.
Oh,
three.
Are you familiar with this?
Look at this.
Look at this statement that,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but the human rights tribunal of Ontario
also found that he harassed them and
created a poisoned housing environment.
It's right.
There you go.
Because he refused to remove issues.
Some sensibilities are more equal than
others,
but that is just what,
why is it that people are so.
Especially in,
particularly with Muslims,
like you'll notice that there's a lot of
people that are,
they will accuse everyone of
Islamophobia yet they'll shit on
Christians.
Yeah.
It's really common like they don't,
it's not that they believe in religious
freedom,
it's that they have like a pet cause and
the pet causes almost like being a and
to a lot of far right people who are
really terrified of Muslims,
like they're trying to like figure out
how to,
how to balance that out with their own
ridiculous leftwing version of it.
Well,
I think there are two elements to it.
One is that they're just afraid to
criticize because bumps,
because they are greater repercussions
to do so than to criticize seventh day
adventist.
So just from a very basic sort of
survival instinct,
but I think secondly,
which is kind of part of the ostrich
parasitics internal,
not speaking of.
There are all sort of erroneous ideas
that people have been infected with.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the Muslim religion is a religion for
the downtrodden,
the Brown people,
the exotic other and so to,
to criticize them when they are a
hapless exotic minority is simply racist
and sexist and people believe that even
though most of the countries that these
people are coming from,
when they come to the west,
not only are they the majority,
they're almost the exclusive majority
like so,
so they are out of I think 56 countries
that constitute
the OIC,
the Organization of Islamic cooperation,
something like 29 or 30 countries that
exclusively Islamic.
They are no longer any religious
minorities.
It's in the order of 99 point nine
something.
So to argue that people who come from
these countries are,
you know,
religious minorities,
religious minorities when they come to
the west,
but they're all coming from countries
where not nevermind that they're the
majority.
They've never interacted with someone
who did not share their faith.
I don't think people understand that if
that happens here,
like you can't turn back from that
without violence.
Right?
Like if,
if,
I mean,
I'm not saying that it would happen in
the United States,
but the fact that it can happen anywhere
means it can happen everywhere.
I mean,
it really can.
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's a big reach on my part to say that
because there is no evidence whatsoever
that it's going to happen here,
but if you really look at some of the
countries that are suffering under this
really oppressive religious ideologies
where women aren't allowed to drive,
where they have to wear a covering all
over their body,
that signifies that they're a part of
this religious sect.
Like if that,
if someone tried to do that today,
like if you had some blonde haired,
blue eyed guy that made all women wear a
certain outfit and they weren't allowed
to drive and they weren't allowed to
have the same rights,
how many people would be standing up for
them?
That's incredible.
Especially if it was a new thing.
It,
there's something about old things like
old ideologies in legitimacy.
So strange.
What is that?
Uh,
while it's exactly what you said,
you take an idea that someone holds.
If he doesn't cloak cloak under the robe
of religion,
you commit them to a psychiatric
institution.
If he says,
no,
but this belief as part of my religion,
suddenly you get a free pass.
That's grotesque,
but to speak to your point about,
well that you are stretching about it
happening in the United States.
You're not stretching it at all.
As a matter of fact,
I've argued at,
for example,
when the,
when trump won,
that if you look at a longterm view of
the issue of Islamic immigration,
if,
if what you focus on is,
uh,
do we have the proper vetting processes
to stop terrorists,
isis terrorists from coming in.
That's a very short term view of the
problem.
But if you recognize that societies will
take often,
very,
very long time before they become
islamized.
It's not as though every single country
that today is Islamic became
instantaneously overnight Islamic.
In some cases it wasn't very,
very quick invasion.
In other cases it took 500 years before
the demographic reality shifted.
And so yes,
if you look at it from the perspective
of 10,
20,
50,
100 years,
the US stands no threat,
but take a longterm view.
I love this quote from I think it was
who said it,
that the United States have all the
clocks and watches we have all the time
in the world.
In other words,
in Shatila.
Eventually God willing,
we will conquer you.
So this is the right way to look at this
issue.
Do you wish to have a society become
more islamized or less?
Let me draw
another analogy.
Uh,
at the end of every day,
you can weigh yourself and one of three
things is going to happen.
You've either lost weight that they get
a weight,
did not change a single ounce or you've
put on weight.
So let's analogize this with Islam.
When Islam comes into a place,
either the society gets better,
nothing changes,
or it gets worse.
Do we have enough data at this point,
after 1400 years to suggest that we can
try to bet what will happen to a
society?
The answer regrettably is yes.
Again,
I hate to have to preface,
of course,
most Muslims are lovely and peaceful and
wish to simply raise their children,
but Islam as an ideology when it comes
into a new society,
is that a good thing?
If yes,
let's alternate Islamic.
If no,
then maybe we should have an honest
conversation about this and honest
conversation is what's really important
because these things get so emotionally
charged like the infamous Ben Affleck,
Sam Harris Debacle on Bill Maher show,
but that to me is a perfect example
because Sam speaks in such a measured
tone and he's so educated about it.
He's not making these big gigantic
leaps,
but people love to jump on him and call
racism.
He sent me some video that I just
watched the other day.
We were a bunch of people are just
taking complete out of context
statements,
attributing to him as being like,
this is what he believes on.
Things.
When if you listen to the full extent of
the conversation,
he's literally saying like that.
I'm going to say something here that
could be taken out of context,
but what I'm saying is imagine if
someone was saying this right,
how do you respond to that?
And they use that as a statement.
I mean there's.
There's so much of that going on.
There's so much,
so dishonest.
Well there's,
there's this weird not me thing that
they're doing.
It's like they,
they're,
I'm not the racist.
He's racist and they get very.
Your racist,
like the Ben Affleck thing,
like he was like,
that is so gross that it's so racist.
Like instead of just discussing this
conversation,
I'm discussing this especially on the
bill Maher show because that shows all
those shows is not to criticize that
show,
but all those shows,
we have a panel of six people.
What you see is a bunch of people
waiting to say something and they have
to jump in and it's almost like they
have to be salacious or they have to be
outrageous just to get heard.
You know,
like everyone.
It's it.
Those kinds of shows promote this sort
of disingenuous communication because
you have to.
You can't be polite like you and I can
be polite.
It's just you and I,
we can talk and we can have these long
form conversations,
but on that show,
you don't have the time to unpack what's
wrong with all ideologies,
all things that tell you how to think.
Forget about whether or not you think it
came from Jesus or the Prophet Muhammad
or Joseph Smith.
Anytime there's a doctrine that tells
you how to think because of some
mystical presence,
some God or Deity or prophet who has
gotten the wisdom of the universe and
you met at must not question it,
and women have to wear veils and dress
up like beekeepers and I mean all that
stuff is very,
very problematic because people are
prone for whatever reason.
I mean some.
I guess it's something that goes back to
tribalism and Alpha male chimpanzee
behavior.
We're prone to follow,
prone to follow leaders.
I mean,
it makes it easier and that's one of the
things you're seeing here.
Well,
what's amazing is that it's one thing to
attack Sam because of the game of
identity politics.
He scores really poorly,
right?
He's a southern California and white
male who doesn't speak any of the
languages that matter Arabic or so on.
And his parents had money.
That's his parents had money.
So I've loved that.
So your parents had money,
you her.
Exactly.
I only recently found out maybe a year
or a year and a half ago when I met him
last,
that his mother is the creator of golden
girls is,
you know.
No,
I didn't even know that.
And I actually,
I,
I just looked at one of the golden girls
that was rerunning and uc,
I think it's Susan Harris or something.
But anyways,
uh,
someone like me who comes from the
Middle East who escape that reality,
someone like Ayaan Hirsi Ali and I had
many people on my show.
Uh,
I don't know how much you followed,
but a lot of people who've all escaped
from this world,
either they still considered themselves
Muslim but know not,
you know,
Muslim light or ex Muslims.
In many cases they will be attached.
So imagine,
you know,
so there was some woman who went to
Wellesley college who doesn't know
anything about Islam,
short of whatever she learned in her
bullshit progressive course.
She would lecture to us what true Islam
is,
not the people who lived under it,
not the people who ran away from it.
She knows better because.
So it's,
it's,
it's really,
it's grotesque.
It's infuriating.
It's stunning.
And it's also confusing because like
when,
when you see them do it,
like anytime someone goes so far
overboard that objective reasoning is
out the window and you're,
you know,
you're so committed to whatever position
that you're in that you can't look at
both sides of it.
I mean,
I,
I could see why a lot of religious
traditions would be comforting to people
remind them of where they came from,
give them pride of their homeland and
give them a personal good feeling.
They're connected to some sort of an
ancient tradition,
right?
As long as it's not oppressing other
human beings.
And there's gotta be some.
I mean I actually cultural patterns of
behavior that people do,
like celebrations like Oktoberfest or
something like that.
Those things promote some sort of pride
like I guess a pride in Germany and
their beer making and all that stuff
without oppressing people,
you know.
But by the way,
this is a good segue to what you're
talking about is something that is
upsetting me these days increasingly so.
So some people are now trying to draw a
distinction between Islam and Islamism.
The reason why I mentioned this is
because Islam has two elements.
There's the spiritual part,
right?
Which is,
you know,
Kinda
like your October fest that prayed this
way,
believe in a god in a monotheistic God
and so on.
But then within Islam is a much larger
component of politics,
political Islam.
So when you say something like,
well,
you know,
we should be attacking Islam.
Islam as if it's something that is
outside of Islam,
that's simply false Islam.
Islam is Islam,
right around the one,
the prime minister of Turkey,
and I can quote many other,
uh,
Islamic experts said Islam is Islam.
The term moderate Islam,
Islam,
and all these other qualifiers are
nonsensical.
Now,
the reason why that upsets me is because
it grants people a false sense of
security and hope.
You know Islam is wonderful,
but we need to attack this separate
thing called Islamism.
Well from day one,
1400 years ago,
Islam was Islam,
Islam.
Now that doesn't mean that there isn't a
spiritual element.
That doesn't mean that most Muslims just
want to practice the spiritual part,
but there is no set of doctrines and as
separate book called radicalized Islam,
Islam,
it all comes from the same texts.
It comes from the Koran,
it comes from the Heidi's,
and it comes from the CEO at the
biography of Muhammad,
so,
so this kind of false narrative that
people are promulgating so that they
seem as though they're not frontally
attacking religion while laudable,
while Nice,
I get that reflex,
it's false and so again,
to go back to our point of talking
honestly,
we need to talk.
Honestly,
there's only Islam.
Some people choose to practice it fully.
Some people choose to ignore the ugly
parts,
but there is no such thing as Islamism.
Islam.
Islam is part of Islam.
Now you're a person that goes out of
your way to say,
no,
we're not talking about the kind sweet
Islamic people that just want to raise
their children now.
So how do you sort of manage those two
ideas that they're the same?
Like when the term radical Islam gets
thrown around,
right?
So radical Islam simply means I really
take my Islam seriously,
right?
It's,
let's draw a silly analogy.
If I don't eat pork in my radical Jew or
am I a Jew right now,
I happen to be Jewish.
I simply ignore the kosher edict that
says,
don't eat pork.
That does.
Why do you do that though?
Because in my case,
I simply identify as Jewish in the sense
that at Judaism is a multi attribute
identity.
It includes a shared history,
shared lineage,
a shit kind of erase what some could
argue it's array,
so it's considered in a lot of people's
ideas so I could still in the same way
that you might identify as coming from
Boston and there's a shared history from
all people who grew up around the time
that you grew up in Boston and there was
a sense of affiliation and tribalism.
Would that reality being,
as far as I'm concerned and for most
Jews,
is exactly that.
We don't necessarily take the religious
elements very seriously.
Now.
That doesn't mean that we are practicing
a light Judaism or non-radical Judaism
where simply ignoring those parts of
Judaism that we choose to ignore,
so there is no such thing as radical
Islam.
There are no books called radical Islam.
There is a set of doctrines called Islam
and then I could do what's called
cafeteria Islam,
which is I pick and choose the parts
that I wished to adhere to.
So again,
the discourse as a false narrative.
I understand the reason for it because
people find it rather Gauche to attack
frontally it religion at least to attack
Islam.
So they have to.
I call this the,
the,
the ISM magic eucharistic rite.
Your ad isn't to something.
It makes it bad.
Islam is good.
Islamism is bad for you.
Um,
I would like to defend you if there's a
lot of people that are listening right
now or offer up some,
not,
not even defend you,
but offer up some information.
Like if you grew up in a place where
being Jewish was lethal,
I mean you,
your life was threatened.
Started on the,
when the civil war broke out,
prior to that you could live in Lebanon
as a do.
People knew that we were Jewish,
but know your place Jew.
That by the way,
is something that I explained when,
when discussing on,
I'm not sure if we've discussed this on
the show,
but it might be worth repeating as we
discussed your past in Lebanon.
How you so,
but so do you know what a dummy is?
Have you heard that term?
Yeah,
you explained it,
but please do again just so dim.
Me As a third class citizen comes out of
Koranic edicts that basically said that
when when Islam comes into a society,
you basically have three choices.
If you're not a Muslim,
you can either convert,
you could either get killed or if you
are people of the book,
meaning Christians and Jews,
meaning people of the book that you're
also monotheistic here also from
Abrahamic faith.
Then you could live as a DM,
me and then me as a protected class,
protected and quotes we tolerate you and
in order to tolerate,
you were going to remind you repeatedly
have your subservient position.
Now at different points across the last
1400 years.
That mechanism was either instituted
very forcefully or more lightly so in
the context of Lebanon,
which is which was a very progressive
and modern country in the Middle Eastern
context.
There wasn't somebody knocking on our
door and loving the pay us or else we're
going to rape your daughters,
but you didn't wear a big star of David
because that might be construed as
inflammatory.
Just like the example that you started
off the show,
you're hurting our sensibilities by
pushing your Judaism on us,
right?
So your your status did not always have
been threatened in that my head is going
to come off at any minute.
Right?
My parents grew up and lived there.
They didn't die,
but once the civil war broke out,
then it became lethally dangerous to be
Jewish.
I mean we were going to be executed.
We left so you never know when we're
going to go from tolerating you to
offload the heads and that's been the
history for the past 1400 years and so
again,
when people think,
but Islam is not that bad.
Look and under lucier a Jews and
Christians and Muslims use to walk
around hand in hand and in Spain around
the 15th,
16th century below me,
yes.
People were not being beheaded everyday,
but you knew your place.
That's not equality and it's kind of
interesting when you talk about this
idea about how people are reluctant to
criticize Islam because they're worried
about the repercussions of this.
It kind of speaks to how rare it is that
people do violate those principles in
those countries because if you do have a
culture that's 99 percent Islamic,
especially if they go by the book,
like every step of the way,
like there's not going to be a lot of
people that are stepping on the line for
fear of the horrific repercussions.
Now psychologically in this country,
you're seeing that for some strange
reason emerging from the left and
emerging from a lot of like really
progressive colleges and universities
where they want to be almost the first
ones to step up and say,
and don't criticize this one particular
religion,
which is,
it's very odd because it's the most
regressive.
It's unbelievable.
It's very,
it's a really strange position to be a
progressive who's reinforcing the
ideologies of a regressive culture
that's very ancient.
But what's incredible is that they'll
come up with ways to defend this
cognitive inconsistency.
And hence,
that's part of the ostrich parasitic
syndrome that I was mentioning.
What,
what are some ways that they defend?
So example.
Uh,
and it just gives you a few
manifestations of ostrich logic.
My friend Mohammed is a very nice guy
and he drinks and he fornicated and he's
very liberal.
So the idea then becomes that as long as
I can identify a single exemplar of a
Islamic person who does not otherwise,
uh,
adhere to what Islam dictates,
then it's not true that Islam is bad.
Now this is,
this is a manifestation of a more
general cognitive bias which goes like
this.
If I walk into class and I say,
look,
a homo sapiens are sexually dimorphic,
they are an eight sex differences
between the two sexes.
Men are bigger than women.
Someone will put up their hand and say,
but my aunt Linda is taller than my
uncle Joe.
Oh Gee.
Darwin is dead.
Right?
So they,
they identify a singular exemplar that
is supposed to falsify a statement that
is only true at the population level.
So here's.
So that's one example why Muhammad is
nice.
Therefore Islam is nice.
Here's a second example.
They point to a particular historical
context where Jews lived in Islamic
countries and weren't killed,
Hae but God's side.
You lived in Lebanon and you still have
your head.
And the torque that I usually give as
well until they were going to cut off my
head.
But secondly,
Jeffrey Dahmer,
if you take,
I think he,
he was guilty of 17 murders,
if you take the number of days that he
lived as an adult until he was caught as
a percentage of the days that he killed
somebody.
90 nine point whatever percent of the
days.
Jeffrey Dahmer is a lovely guy.
So it's unfair for you to say that
Jeffrey Dahmer is a mean guy given that
99 percent of the time,
he's nice.
So what you have to basically do is take
each of these ostrich logic arguments
and analogize how the Arctic they are,
but it's very exhausting because the
bent,
as you said,
of all these progressives,
is to do what ever they can to protect
the ideology.
And so it becomes exhausting to
consistently have to try to fight
through all the clutter.
And it's not a thought that it's not
something that is structured with
objective reasoning.
It's something that's structured with
their own particular ideology that does
not want to criticize this one segment
of the human population that they think
is being persecuted and meanwhile,
if you think about throughout currently
in the world,
which ideology persecutes the most
number of other people.
So if you talk about bloody borders,
right?
Islam has fought with Buddhists,
Islam fights with animists,
Islam fights with Jews,
Islam fights with Christians.
Islam fights with the Beth and monks as
right,
so in other words,
Islam doesn't necessarily make for very
good neighbors.
Why?
Because again,
not withstanding the fact that most
Muslims are lovely and just want to
raise their kids Islam as a supremacist
ideology,
it basically says that the world is
meant to all be united under the flag
of.
Now.
Some people take that seriously.
Others don't,
but the doctrines of Islam are very
clear.
We should all submit to Islam.
So even if 95 percent of Muslims don't
adhere to that tenant,
if only five percent do,
that means we're always going to have
friction.
In some cases it'll be like Lebanon.
By the way,
I've predicted that in Europe.
This is on record,
we can probably find that that in Europe
within 15,
20,
25,
50 years,
we're going to have Lebanon all over the
place and now it's starting to happen.
Right?
At one point we were having daily
attacks all over Europe,
so.
So again,
if you're going to increase Islamic
immigration to the West,
of course most people are nice and just
want to escape through a better world,
but are you willing to take the risks
for what's about to happen?
Are you willing to accept people whose
cultural and religious values are
perfectly antithetical to yours?
So example,
if you do pew surveys from around the
Middle East or Islamic countries about
your views on Jews while you'll get
things like 95 to 99 percent Jew hatred.
So if I am,
if I am a Canadian Jew,
right,
and I see that 50,000 Syrians are going
to come in,
is it that I'm filled with hatred
towards Syrians or am I simply someone
who calculates statistical regularities
and basically says that out of 50,000
people,
if 95 percent have academic Jew hatred
as part of their identity,
do I have a right to be concerned about
this?
I'm not worried about Haitians.
They're black people.
I'm not racist.
I'm not worried about the Vietnamese.
Right?
I'm worried about the cultural and
religious baggage that you bring in.
What about your views towards cliteracy
as or homosexuality or a religious
minorities or black dogs?
Darwin forbid,
if you're a black dog,
your dog,
Muhammad hated dogs,
but he particularly hated black dogs.
Uh,
so again,
so what do they do with blocked on the
go,
go online and you'll see some pretty
ugly,
uh,
animal cruelty,
they're not very tolerant towards dogs.
Uh,
if you touch a dog before you're heading
to prayer,
this is called [inaudible].
It's in pure,
by the way,
the Kuffar,
the non Muslims are also nudges.
They're there.
They're there as impure as urine and
blood and sperm and feces,
so should I feel bad that there is an
ideology that considers me an impure
quality?
Now,
does that mean that all Muslims are like
that?
Of course not.
Ninety nine percent of the Muslims I've
met have been lovely and many of them
are my friends,
but we should be able to talk about
what's inside those books and those
books are not radical Islam.
They're Islam.
Well,
let me ask you this.
What's the alternative like say for
Syrian refugees,
I mean any kind,
caring person who has concern for our
fellow human beings sees these people
fleeing and sees the horrific conditions
that they're.
That they're confronted with their own
country and they really don't have a lot
of options and they're trying to escape
to the west.
What?
What are the options?
What do you do?
There are no clear answers.
I would certainly say you first place
the people who are most at risk in those
societies on the front of the queue.
So you bring the Yazidi women,
you'll bring the Christians who are
being persecuted women.
But what about the father?
If the dad is with the wife and the
children,
you can't just have the father stayed
back behind the tent and you let the mom
go to Toronto with the kid.
No,
fair enough.
Uh,
what I was saying though is that let
people who are non Islamic who are
fleeing those areas at the front of the
queue first,
but isn't that,
isn't that religious persecution?
I mean,
or at the very least it's prejudice,
right?
I mean you're,
you're,
you're singling people out because of
their ideology or because of what
religion they're from,
not because of their past behavior or
any predictors whatsoever about their
future behavior.
But we do have some statistical
irregularity about what types of values
those guys are going to come with.
So I'm not suggesting we closed the
door.
Wouldn't that in a way.
I mean,
just to play devil's advocate,
wouldn't that in a way kind of put the
Muslims in Toronto who do immigrant,
which would have picked that city who
tried to immigrate to Canada in the same
sort of a position that your family was
in in Lebanon where you were hiding the
fact that you would choose.
No one has an inalienable right to
immigrate anywhere.
Correct.
So if you wish to immigrate to the West
than leave every single syllable that
constitutes a belief attitude,
position,
value that is contrary to ours at the
door and then welcome in my brother.
But man,
isn't that a crazy thing to say to
someone whose entire life and their
ideology is a big part of their identity
and who they are,
like how they view the world.
So that's the structure for which they
interface with other human beings.
But if those values.
So let's suppose that in a way I agree
with you overall when I talk about the
entire human population,
that it would be wonderful if we did
that,
but from individual to individual,
we know about the trials and
tribulations that people go through.
On a day to day life and religious
freedom and a religious ideology in many
cases helps people get through the pains
of life.
It helps them get through the struggles.
I'm not saying that it's rational,
but I am saying that in many ways it's a
scaffolding for their own personal
behavior.
Got It.
You would have to then ensure that your
religious practice is exclusively
practice privately.
Never should there ever be an intrusion
into the public sphere.
No.
Asking for prayer rooms at the
university.
The example that you gave is the slight
creeping she had.
Right?
It's the slow.
It's,
uh,
so my next book is called tentatively
might change death of the West by a
thousand cuts,
right?
It's the idea that when you take,
again,
the parable of the frog,
when you put it in boiling water and you
do it very slowly,
the frog,
if you do it very,
very slowly,
if it falls below a just noticeable
difference,
it doesn't notice that the temperature
is rising until it's too late and it
boils to death.
Right?
So this idea of just noticeable
difference is something that's very
important in this conversation.
We're not going to get Islam analyzed
overnight,
but Egypt before it became Islamic,
used to be non Islamic.
Once upon a time.
Today it's about 10 percent.
The Coptic Christians,
Turkey is now 99 percent Islamic.
One day.
It wasn't Iran.
The Great Persian empires were not
Islamic today.
It's almost exclusively Islamic.
So the United States and Canada are not
going to become,
uh,
Islamic,
you know,
in the next 10 years.
But give it enough time,
have a long enough view of history and I
worry about your grandchildren and mine.
Uh,
and so we,
that's how you have an honest
conversation.
And I'm not sure what the answer is.
One possibility which I've with folks on
my
show who are trained lawyers,
is that there are provisions in the law,
at least in the United States,
to the Claire and ideology as being
suspicious,
right?
So in the same way that you could say
that Nazi-ism is seditious to our values
or communism,
they are elements of Islam.
The nonspiritual parts that it doesn't
take Einstein to recognize that they are
perfectly antithetical to every single
value that you and I with the whole deer
as Westerners.
So like what?
What would be some of those volumes?
So take for example,
Shetty,
aloe,
right,
which is the Islamic law by which you
organize society.
The first premise of Islamic law is that
the a crime,
its severity and its punishment depends
on the identity of the perpetrator and
the victim.
So imagine the idea and the American
constitution that justice is blind.
Well,
that is already violated as the most
fundamental tenets of Sharia law.
If a Muslim kills a Jew,
it's very,
very different crime than if a Jew kills
a Muslim.
You can just go,
go look up reliance of the traveler,
which is the English translation of
shadow law.
And you'll see all these things.
So why should we tolerate this kind of
stuff?
Right?
Come in my Muslim brothers,
but keep the stuff that you yourself
escaped from out of our country.
We don't want it.
And if you keep it out,
come in and let's grow together and hug
it out.
But why should I be tolerant towards the
intolerable?
I,
I agree with you in theory,
but I think the problem is as soon as
you tell someone to not follow certain
aspects of their ideology,
those aspects become even more
attractive and especially if they
consider the west to be decadent and
filled with sin and fornicating and
drinking and all the,
all the things that they think are
disgusting.
And then these people are the ones who
are telling you that you can't follow
the word of God has brought down by the
profit from up on high.
It becomes even more attractive to them.
So what do we do?
So what's your truck's psychedelic
drugs?
Everyone gets on mushrooms and I'm not
kidding.
I really.
I really think you need transcendent
experiences to escape from the day to
day vibration of normal life.
How about just the commitment to reason
and science?
It would be wonderful if we could do
that,
but people are so terrified of death and
they're so terrified of the unknown and
they're so terrified of not having
structure.
People love having ideological structure
that they can govern their life by real
clear,
established rules.
Man.
People get mad at me when I wear a fanny
pack and I'm not joking.
One of the reasons why where it is
because people think it's disgusting.
Like you think it's disgusting that I
will have a bag around my waist that I
can keep my keys and phone in.
It's,
but we have structure.
You know,
men aren't supposed to wear sandals.
if you're a man and you're wearing high
heels open toed,
you will get
ridiculed.
Why?
Because we have a structure and this
structure,
we don't.
I mean,
that's a bad example,
but it's not really because it's along
the same lines of thinking that we would
expect you to behave like we do so that
we don't have to worry about your
behavior.
I like gentlemen,
I like a man with a tie and a suit
because I'm pretty sure that guy's not
going to spit at me and stab me and rob
me.
We have these ideas about people that
dress and behave a certain way.
You know,
if someone,
if you're in a business meeting and the
guy starts swearing,
he'll like,
Whoa,
I all bets are off.
This man's not establishing the
gentleman's protocol.
He's not following the standard business
oriented,
you know,
I would just like to exchange numbers
and funds with you protocol,
and so I don't understand what his
behavior is going to be.
He's unpredictable.
He could be a random street thug with a
hoodie.
You know,
that was a thing for awhile.
People were scared of young black men
with hoodies on because a gentleman
would not wear a hoodie on the street.
That's a dangerous person.
By the way.
Our brains have evolved to think this
way.
Right?
And so this idea,
you were asking me earlier,
give me some examples of ostrich logic.
So this kind of Hashtag not all right
now.
That again is idiotic.
Why?
Because when we think about it,
let's not talk about Islam for a second.
If you're going down a dark alley and
you see for young men,
forget about hoodies and pants down just
for young men.
So all you have described is the fact
that they're young and they're men.
If you see for young men versus four
elderly women just because of your
statistical regularity that you
calculate,
which is more which group is more likely
to end violence on you,
then you might avoid the alley with the
four young men,
even though not all young men,
right?
Even though the probability that a young
man is going to jump you and gang rape
you and Mug you and stab you as a small
one,
but your brain has evolved to calculate
those statistical regularities and to
then be very careful,
be very risk averse and putting yourself
in harm's way.
So again,
even though most Muslims are very nice
and very lovely,
I think we have enough data right now.
If we look at the last since 2000,
11,
2000,
one nine slash 11,
there's been over 30,000 terror attacks
committed in the name of Islam,
right?
I challenge anybody in your comments
section to list me another ideology that
comes remotely close.
If you added up every single other
ideology since 2001,
you wouldn't come up to 100.
So what is the statistical numbers that
you need to see before you're able to
simply say,
look,
let's have an honest conversation.
Not withstanding that,
not all Muslims and most are nice.
Is there a problem with Islam?
Yes.
It's not radical Islam.
It's not Islam Islam.
It's not militant violent extremism.
Let's stop with the bullshit euphemisms.
There are inherent elements,
contents within Islam that are
problematic.
It's not my job to find a way to get rid
of them,
but if you wish to be part of our
western societies,
then you need to find the way to expunge
that stuff.
If you do it,
welcome my brother.
We're all brothers.
If you don't,
then I should show preference to people
who share similar cultural values.
To me that's.
That's called survival instinct.
Now what about people that would say
that there's inherent problems with the
Jewish religion?
There's inherent problems with
subscribing to that ideology that there
had been persecuting Islamic people in
Palestine that they've been prosecuting
and treating Islamic people as inferior
to Jewish people.
That's not me.
I know you're not necessarily saying it,
but that's all part of ostrich logic.
That's what I call the Crusades.
Right.
And it's not me who actually came up
with the.
Right.
So every time we did,
but more like,
it's,
it's a,
it's a way of saying like,
but bro,
but what about the Crusades,
Amal?
Huh?
Where's that from?
I think I first saw it and he'll be
happy that I'm giving a shadow.
I think a guy on youtube who goes by the
name of t and crowds or Kraut and t,
he's a German youtuber.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I meant like,
that's not from a language or anything.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's like saying,
Bro,
let's Duh,
Duh.
Exactly.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Exactly.
But the Crusades,
as soon as you,
as,
as soon as you point to some Islamic
ugly reality than someone points,
but bro,
what about Israel but isn't ended up
valid comparison?
I mean really,
but you're kind of claiming and
ideology,
right?
Right.
I mean,
but when you're saying you're Jewish and
I support you saying this 100 percent,
especially considering of all people,
you should be in some ways proud of who
you are considering that you come from a
line of oppressed people that escaped a
horrible situation.
A no one is arguing that there is a
monopoly of ugliness that only stems
from Islam.
Jews can engage in ugliness,
Christians,
atheists.
Why subscribed to any ideology then?
Because in the case of a,
you're talking about specifically
Israel,
any,
any ideology,
any.
Not necessarily Israel,
which is a land,
but I reject all the religious elements
of Judaism,
so,
so why are you a Jew?
Because I am part of A.
People are part of a shared history,
so it's like I'm Italian,
your attack kind of thing.
You're a time,
right?
I,
I belong to the lineage.
And the same way,
by the way,
I recently put up a clip on my channel
where I talked about academic lineage.
So in the same way that you could build
a genealogy of your family tree or of a
people's,
you could do what's called an academic
genealogy.
So for example,
my doctoral supervisor is my academic
father and then I could look to see who
was his academic supervisor and who was
his academic supervisor and do the
martial arts.
Is that right?
Yeah,
there's a direct lineage.
So I could literally go back to some of
the founders and only three or four
generations,
um,
with some of the pioneers of,
of psychology.
And so I belong to that particular
tribe,
right?
It comes to academia when it comes to my
ethnicity,
to my religious heritage.
I belong to a group called Jews.
Now that doesn't mean that all the Booga
Booga bullshit in Judaism I buy into,
I rejected.
So it makes me already somewhat less
dangerous.
And that if there are any ugly elements
within Judaism,
they're simply not going to be
instantiated because I'm openly
rejecting all that shit.
Right?
I understand that you as an individual
or me as an individual and most Jews in
the west,
I think would fit into my category by
the way,
later we should talk about four and a
half hour talk I had with a Hasid,
a very religious Jew.
Let's do it flying ticket to California
on a second.
Now,
if most Muslims said,
look,
there's tons of historical elements in
Islamic societies that's beautiful.
Islamic architecture,
Islamic Science,
Islamic,
some Islamic philosophy,
uh,
one of the first intellectuals and in
modern history,
big history,
so so I could be Muslim and that I come
from a shared lineage of people and I
could be very proud of that,
but I can also have the moral compass
and the moral fortitude to say,
but there is stuff in my book that is
truly grotesque and no amount of
obfuscation and re interpretive dancing
could alter that ugliness,
right?
There's no way to take kill,
kill,
taken a suppressor outbreak,
resume killing.
There is no way to take that and
reinterpreted using modern sensibilities
to mean at killing with caresses,
right?
Let's not play this reform game,
so be proud of your cultural identity if
and if that incorporates an Islamic
identity grade,
but reject all the bullshit.
Right?
And so I think that's where Judaism and
Christianity at this point is somewhat
different from Islam.
For most people who are Islamic,
even if they don't necessarily believe
it,
they'll feel very reticent to openly
admitted that they despise a lot of the
ugliness they'll say it's not true.
It doesn't exist.
You didn't understand that.
You misinterpreted that Reza Aslan
Bullshit,
right?
No,
be honest about it.
Say it exists.
Say you're rejected and let's move
forward,
but stop skating.
Well then there's people like Majid
Nawaz who has,
he identifies as being a Muslim,
but he does reject those things,
but he says that you could reform them
and measured,
and I have had in case some of you
viewers don't know this.
Uh,
I invited at one point two four to chat
and uh,
uh,
he refused because I think he refused
and I,
I can't put intent into his mind,
but I'm analyzing his rejection to chat
with me.
I think it's because he sees that I'm
going to call them out on a lot of his
narrative.
Well,
no one knows why someone rejects.
I'm sure.
Did he openly rejected?
Like he has no room for it in the
future,
whoever.
Yeah,
I mean,
at this point I retract that invitation.
So even if you want it to run,
there's an expression in Arabic.
I'm going to use this for a second.
Imagine this is the pen.
He's holding a pen.
A.
Oh,
I'm holding the people at home
listening.
The vast majority of guys listening.
Imagine that.
This spend,
we're a cork.
The cork of a wine bottle.
There's an expression in Arabic,
which I'll say in Arabic.
Some people have heard,
mentioned before.
The expression is this guy to bill's bb.
Discardable is bb is to get drunk simply
by smelling the court.
Right?
So I look,
I'm smelling it.
I'm already getting drunk.
That's what measured in there was his,
he,
he gets people drunk with his,
uh,
hopeful reform message.
Sounds so liberal.
That sounds so hopeful.
Say the expression of this scheduled
bills,
baby.
I can't even make that noise in my face,
but that this schedule booths but like,
but like Yanni.
Oh,
there you go.
Now,
do you want me to have the rest of this
conversation in Arabic be fascinating.
I wish I could speak.
It sounds cool.
Actually.
What happens with a lot of the guests
that I bring in on my show who are
Arabic,
we always start off the star of our show
speaking only in Arabic because for most
westerners it's fetishize.
It's so excited.
Like,
oh my goodness,
that's so alien to the way you speak
English.
The sounds right,
but so going back to magic,
I think what maybe his heart is in the
right place.
I don't.
I'm not.
I'm not trying to infer or imply that
he's diabolical are duplicitous.
I think he probably truly believes that
he's doing something worthwhile.
The problem is that it's not as though
until measured.
The West came along.
No one had ever thought about this idea
of reforming Islam.
Jesus really?
We never thought of that in the last
1400 years,
but the reality is that there are
elements within the doctrines of Islam
that simply don't permit for this
reformation to take place and even if it
could take place,
we don't necessarily have the time to
wait another 400 years while we
deliberate how each syllable and each of
the problematic passages should be
reinterpreted while people spot are
being stacked up all over the world and
so therefore I think that there needs to
be a much more direct intervention and
what I mean by direct intervention,
no,
there doesn't need to be reformed,
doesn't need to be interpreted.
It needs to be expunged.
These types of ideas.
If Judaism has certain ideas that are a
belligerent to women's cliteracy,
then I want those ideas and Judaism out.
They don't belong in the public arena of
ideas.
That's it.
Now,
how did Christianity reform and Islam
did not?
How did that go about happening?
Because at one point in time,
Christianity,
Christianity was a very repressive
religion and the apostasy,
the idea of it was much more oppressed
than today.
Right now,
like Islam is the only religion that I'm
aware of.
I mean,
maybe there's more that I'm just
ignorant to where if you leave the
religion they can kill you.
Absolutely.
I mean,
that's like,
that's what God wants.
God wants you to die because you don't
believe in them anymore.
What?
I've always said that Islam is the
perfect meme of plex.
So are you familiar with that term
means?
No.
So a meme is a term that Richard Dawkins
coined in his book in 1976.
Selfish,
selfish gene.
Thank you.
Uh,
where he was analogizing the idea of a
gene.
Gene's propagate,
correct?
Well,
memes are packets of information that
spread from one brain to another.
And so means also spread.
We are both a biological and a cultural
animal,
right?
Both are gene spread and our ideas
spread.
So a meme is something that can go.
So if you read my books,
I am infecting your brain with my memes,
with my ideas.
Correct.
A library is a collection of memes.
So.
And Mima.
Plex is a collection of means that in
this case falls under a religious idea.
Ideology.
Well,
Islam is the perfect Mimo plex in what
sense?
And that it's contents are made to
spread.
For example,
Judaism.
You mentioned earlier Judaism,
you don't have any Jews there are in the
world.
John spot 12.
What?
No,
I don't know.
I'm still going to ask you what you want
to just not to put you on the spot.
How many,
how many?
Seven billion people in the world?
I would guess there would be somewhere
in the neighborhood of a billion Jews.
A billion.
Uh,
Jamie,
you want to take $500?
Million maybe.
I'm going to get.
I'm going to take a very conservative
guests.
I'm gonna.
Change it to 500 million.
I'm so glad that we did this.
You're going to be shocked how many
there is somewhere between 13 to 15
million Jews.
That is more than that in New York.
Now you're out of your fucking mind.
I'll just look it up.
Shut the off.
Skype talking crazy.
He's an agent.
Let let,
let.
I'm a Zionist shell.
Let,
let,
let Jamie now do his little google
magic.
Thirteen to $15.
Million.
$50.
There's more idiots in America than
there are Jews and that's only an
Arkansas.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm just going.
Is that really it?
Well,
think about how many Nobel Prize winners
are Jews and 25 to 30 percent.
It's incredible,
right?
And that,
that,
by the way,
some people will say there is a genetic
element,
but even if here we go,
what do we got?
Fourteen dollars million.
200,000.
Between 30 and $50 million.
That's perfectly accurate.
What is the enlarged?
What does that mean?
The world most?
The most.
The largest number of possibles.
20 million.
You know that's like given I've never
seen 20 million.
It's usually the highest I've seen is 16
million.
It says core Jewish and and large
Jewish.
What does that like dudes will get
converted because their wife makes him.
I don't know,
my uncle did that,
but by,
by,
by strict,
by strictly conversion allows that would
not be allowed and not allowed to
convert for ulterior motives.
What?
Alternative motives?
He wants to be spiritual.
It's a spiritual awakening.
Well,
went through the whole process.
He went to Hebrew school.
The whole process has to be for no
ulterior motive.
It can't be because my wife would not
marry me otherwise,
but I think he did it because she wanted
him to do and then he decided to do it
because it was what,
you know.
I mean,
I get it.
But anyway,
let's go back.
So there are,
there are about 13 to 15 million Jews.
There are one point 6 billion Muslims,
one fifth of humanity to every one Jew,
there's 100 Muslim.
Which ideology is more successful based
on propagation,
Islam,
or Judaism.
Right.
Now,
why is that?
Well,
take for example,
conversion laws for,
as you said about.
Was it your cousin?
No,
my uncle,
my uncle.
Uh,
in the way that he did it,
as you said,
it's a very assiduous process.
It takes a long time before and as a
matter of fact,
the rabbis are supposed to try to
dissuade you from converting to Judaism
because that in a sense tests your
faith,
your desire to change an Islam.
Do you know what you have to do to
convert?
What?
I won't say it because if I actually say
it in Arabic,
that converted converted and therefore
if I leave it,
but basically you just have to say the
Shahada,
which it's like the.
I testify,
wow.
It's a once one sentence and then that's
it.
Boom ran.
If you leave your dead in Judaism,
there isn't that.
How about laws?
Laws for marriage.
A Muslim man can marry up to four women
including non Muslim women and convert
them,
but a Muslim woman cannot do the other
way around,
so the whole structure of Islam is built
on the propagation of the belief system,
so just by that,
which one is going to be more dangerous?
One is a proselytizing religion.
The other one you're not allowed to in
Judaism to proselytize,
you're not supposed to try to convert
others and Islam is to proselytize.
You have to now in different countries,
they'll do it in different ways.
In the West where they are in the
minority,
they'll do it through interfaith
exchanges,
but the interfaith exchanges are always
the Muslim telling the non Muslim how
great our religion is and why you should
convert.
It's never.
It's never given.
Take a.
So just going back to your early point
about Israel and so on.
Yes,
of course.
Undoubtedly there are some Israelis that
do very bad things to their non Jewish
brothers.
No question.
But when we're talking about existential
threats to our western ways,
you and I probably don't stay up
worrying about radical Jews.
No,
no,
don't.
Um,
I wonder what it is about people that
makes us so susceptible to ideological
thinking and still,
and whether or not it's ever expungeable
you know,
whether or not it's ever something that
we can eradicate from the thought
process.
It just seems inherent to being a
person.
So much so that I recognize it in
myself.
Like,
here's a perfect example.
I ran into a guy just a few days ago and
he was,
he said hello to me.
And then he explained to me that he
trains Jujitsu with the Machados and
immediately we were like brothers
because that's my lineage,
right?
So it's like,
oh,
what's up man?
Like immediately.
And I'm like,
that is so weird.
It's so weird.
You know,
like I,
I understand like when I talk to someone
like how long you train?
Twelve years.
Oh,
okay.
So you understand me and I understand
you.
Uh,
where do you,
where do you train Machado's Oh,
we come from the same thing.
Oh,
we're like,
Bro,
this is a weird thing.
Like I'd give that guy a ride.
I don't even know him.
You know what I mean?
But that's,
that's the case with religion.
That's the case with,
with many things.
It's the case with ethnic ethnicities.
Oftentimes with even with state pride,
like we branch off into groups and we
have micro groups and macro groups and
it gets real weird when we do this,
but we all do it.
So to speak exactly about this ever
granular way to compare it to
compartmentalize us versus them.
Let me mention the Hasidic.
Oh yeah,
please do.
Because the reason I,
the reason that's a good segue is
because I actually raised it with him on
the plane.
I used to live in an area in Montreal
called Mall for the Montreal is out
there.
They'll know where it is,
where there are a lot of acidic Jews,
so now you would think that within this
very small group of people called Jews
within an even smaller group of people
called Hasidic Orthodox Jews,
once you're an Orthodox Jew,
you're an Orthodox Jew.
No,
on this side of the street are the
Polish Orthodox Jews on this side of the
street are the Hungarian Orthodox Jews
and I wouldn't be caught dead marrying
my daughter to those heathen pigs from
the other side of the street.
So in other words,
our ability to create a US versus them
distinctions,
as you said is,
is infinite.
That's what,
by the way,
I hate most about religion and not only
Islam,
right?
Certainly every abrahamic religion has a
very clear delineation between us and
them.
Uh,
if we are Christians,
we're going to have in the rest of you
who haven't accepted Jesus are going to
hell if you are Jewish,
they are the Jews and they are the
goals,
right?
Then the gentiles.
If you are Muslim,
of course there are US Muslim believers
and all of you could fought,
right?
And so it's an inherent part of
Abrahamic faith to play on this very
innate mechanism of tribalism.
US versus them.
It's grotesque.
And it's also what happened in Iraq when
we
got rid of Saddam Hussein,
it created a civil war between two rival
factions of Islam,
Shia and the Sunni,
which most people had no idea that was
even a situation over there.
Exactly.
But should we,
you want to talk?
So I was very interested in asking him
things that I actually thought about
studying scientifically as part of my
research.
So one of the things that I study as you
know,
is,
well,
I apply evolutionary psychology,
all sorts of things.
One of which is mating preferences.
You know,
are there certain mating preferences
that are universally true irrespective
of culture.
Right?
And the answer of course is yes.
So whether you go to the Animal Momo
tribe in Brazil,
a closed society,
or you go walk around in La,
they are certain things that men will
look for in women and other things that
women will look for.
And men that tend to be universal's for
clear evolutionary reasons.
So I was interested at one point in
studying the mating preferences of the
Hasidic community.
Again,
the idea being that here you're taking a
community that culturally and
religiously is very close where the
cultural and religious brainwashing is
very,
very strong.
And in this moment is movement that
you're making with your hands.
Does that represent the sheet with the
hole in it as you're doing this thing?
Keeps doing this thing with your hand?
Must Be.
It must be a subconscious thing.
Yes.
Is that a real.
I don't know if it's real.
I'm adding her.
Might be the ostrich thing.
It must be.
Maybe it's a,
it's a find out if we're talking about
explaining what we're talking about,
the idea,
the idea is that when a hasidic couple
has sex,
they have a sheet between them where
they make a hole where the genitalia
goes and that's how you get it all.
That's what I thought.
Why you kept doing that.
Maybe it was a freudian thing.
Uh,
and so my idea was at one point is to
see if I can get access to the Hasidic
community,
which will probably not be easy to get
into the Hasidic community and ask them
about their mating preferences.
And so it was a small idea I had over an
afternoon and then kind of dropped it
and moved on to other things.
But here I was sitting with a couple of
hesitant couple and I thought,
okay,
I can't do a scientific study,
but at least I could come up with some
anecdotes to discuss.
And so I actually asked them things
like,
uh,
you know,
can you,
can we talk about some meeting
preferences that take place within the
Hasidic community?
And there were some really incredible
insights that came out.
So for example,
the Wa,
the wife said that one of the attributes
that she absolutely was looking for an
it perspective made was that he be
taller than her.
Okay.
And it turns out that this is the,
this is called assortative mating.
Birds of a feather flock together.
So if you look at naturally occurring
couples,
it is almost never the case that the
woman is taller than the man.
There was actually a study done with 720
couples as single couple.
The woman was taller than the men.
So here's an example of a very basic
physical desire and this case,
I just need the map not not to be tall,
just taller than me.
Right.
That was replicating in a completely
different context.
And the Hasidic community,
I even asked them about things like,
well,
we'll a hasidic woman ever look at a non
Hasidic guy that's walking down the
street of bad boy that has tattoos and
greased back here and you know,
the swimmer's body and desire him or has
the cultural
and religious brainwashing been so great
that her eyes are shut off to these
possibilities?
And she actually said that.
No,
I mean the bottom line as Eo Wilson
said,
the jeans hold culture on a leash.
In other words,
no matter how much cultural and
religious brainwashing you have,
if you scratch far enough,
you'll get the same human nature.
And that's what I basically got from my
conversation with them.
That's a fascinating way of describing
it.
The genes hold culture,
lead shot,
Mike.
Well that's great.
That's the o Wilson.
That's a perfect way of saying it.
That's a nice.
Every now and then you hear a phrase and
you're like,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's,
he's,
you know,
I wish you could get him on your show.
I'm not sure if he's now probably 85.
Do you know who Eo Wilson is?
No,
I do not.
So eo Wilson is a very famous,
a scientist at Harvard.
I've heard the name,
I just don't know.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
He's a by training.
He's an entomologist,
a insect scientist.
He specifically studies,
uh,
the social social ants basically.
And so he looks at things like
reciprocal altruism,
kin selection,
all of these mechanisms of altruism in
the context of b.
here's another quote that he has that I
love.
Communism slash socialism,
great system,
wrong species.
What he's basically saying is that that
political system of we're all equal
under communism is a great idea,
but it applies to social ants that
doesn't apply to humans.
Yeah.
So he's got these wonderful pithy
quotes.
I wish,
I mean I know that Robert Sapolsky is
great,
but if Robert Sapolsky is great,
you need to get Eo Wilson on this
podcast and.
Well if it's possible I'll look into it.
Where did you say he is?
He's at Harvard.
Harvard.
So I'd probably have to come to him.
Product Daddy travels a lot at this
stage.
It was probably,
well I'd be willing.
I'm going to be back there eventually,
I'm sure.
So how often do you go back to Boston?
Well I haven't been in awhile.
I'm going to try and get there in the
spring.
I'm thinking about filming my next
Netflix special there was before I
started.
Right,
okay.
Trying to figure it out.
It's either going to be there here.
I think.
Very nice.
Those was my two options.
Boston or California?
Very nice.
Seven figure either my current or
former.
Right,
right.
I don't know.
But um,
so when you talk to this guy for four
plus hours,
um,
and my,
my wife was pissed by the way.
Why?
Because you didn't talk to her because
she felt ignored.
She felt like she was getting bored and
she have to take care of the kids while
I was having this one is my fight.
I thought later winter it had been
wonderful if we could have taped it and
I could have released this conversation
on my show.
Oh yeah.
Because it was so honest to keep in
touch with this guy and so we,
we exchange actually asked him
permission.
I'm,
I didn't mention that.
I mentioned.
I said,
would you mind,
I'm going on this very popular showed
would you?
He goes,
no,
go ahead and feel free.
And so it would be cool to get you guys
together and moderate.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
That would be cool.
Well,
now,
um,
it was an amicable conversation and I
really pushed him very politely.
Um,
so at one point I said to him,
you know,
what would be the evidence that you
would need to see to have any
questioning of your faith and his
answer,
which is a classic argument from the,
I don't know if you know the term God of
the gaps.
Are you familiar with that?
So God of the gaps is basically at one
point when we didn't know much in
science,
God could be found explaining everything
right?
Why does it happen?
Well,
God does it right now.
We find out that there is a very clear
material explanation for for a
lightening.
So now that's often how God goes and
hide somewhere else and now he
constantly finds the small gaps where
science hasn't yet been able to uncover
an explanation and he hides there.
That's called the god of the gaps
argument,
and so he used the granddaddy of God,
of the guy.
He goes,
if you take me back to the Big Bang and
you show me that there was no god at
that point,
then I'm willing to renounce my faith to
which I answered.
Even if I were able to do that,
you would still find a way to finagle
your way into justifying your belief.
In other words,
there is no amount of evidence that I
could ever provide you that would shake
your foundation.
So we really got into some heavy stuff.
By the way,
that's one of the differences between,
I think in his case he's an extremist
Jew in the sense that he is the most
practicing of Jews.
Well,
how come we could have this very,
very difficult conversation and leave at
the end shaking hands both richer for it
and no one's heads come off.
Well,
you were also a Jew though.
I mean,
did it help?
what if he had that conversation with a
Muslim?
Don't you think that maybe maybe there's
more intention but nobody's head would
be at least the John United Airlines.
Right?
My point is that I think part of Jewish
tradition,
even when you,
for example,
go to the yeshiva to study,
say mood,
is that there is this mechanism of we
constantly argue about everything.
Nothing is settled.
We have to debate over everything,
so you have to have that openness of
spirit to have your ideas question and I
think that if already Islam we're open
to that a bit more than maybe it would
be in a better place.
I've heard some of the most compelling
arguments against the big bang from
religious people and what?
Give me some of those,
the argument against it is you are not
willing to believe that there is a
creator,
that there is some sort of a system that
was put in place by a much higher power
beyond what we can describe,
but you're willing to believe that
everything came out of nothing,
right?
Something smaller than the head of a pin
for some reason that no one's ever
figured out.
And the only evidence that we have is
the radio wave echoes of this event,
right?
So this is A.
I mean,
I've heard similar arguments.
I mean Thomas is an acquaintance,
is the guy who always argued,
I think in the twelfth century,
but the first mover that you could
always go back and say at time zero.
What started that?
What started the,
uh,
I don't think you could ever really a
ultimately shake somebody foundations,
right?
There's no amount of money.
Forget about the idea of shaking
someone's belief system.
It is odd that we're all willing to
believe the most insane version of the
creation of the universe ever without a
doubt,
like every person of science,
people that believe in genes and atoms
and subatomic particles and corks and
glue ons,
and they believe that at one point in
time there was something that was
smaller than the head of a pin that
became the infinite space that we see in
front of us that's constantly expanding
and so infant that.
One of the things that Lawrence Krauss
really,
really fucked my mind up when he was
here.
He was explaining to me that when we're
seeing the universe and we're talking
about 13 point 7 billion years or
whatever it is you're seeing as it was.
Well,
yes,
not just seeing it as it was,
but he said you're only seeing the
observable universe because the universe
itself is moving faster than the light
that you see from it.
So it's entirely possible that it goes
back far further than that.
You just can't see it.
Right.
And you'll listen to Richard Dawkins,
the guy that we talked about earlier
about selfish gene has a wonderful
concept.
It's called middle world.
Have you heard this before?
No,
but I read it.
Or jrr Tolkien's middle earth.
Is that.
Oh,
that's a load of ranks.
Okay.
I'm not,
I'm not too familiar with that stuff,
but he talks about middle world.
The idea being that our brains evolved
to understand phenomena at a level that
our brain interacts with.
Right.
He caused that middle world so that
which is that the cosmological level
right at the Lawrence Krauss level of
cosmology or at the national level,
quantum,
quantum physics.
It's so esoteric that our brains haven't
evolved to understand phenomena at that
level.
Right.
So in a sense,
it's counter intuitive for us to even do
that.
I mean,
think about it when you and I are
actually most physicists when they study
things at those levels,
they will tell you that this stuff is so
esoteric.
Right?
Richard Fineman the very famous
physicist,
but I said,
you know,
if you,
if you think you understand quantum
physics,
you don't understand quantum physics or
something to that effect,
that it is so esoteric and difficult for
human brains to understand things at
that level,
small or very big so,
but that not withstanding,
that doesn't mean that scientists
succumb to belief just like religious
people do because scientists have
epistemic humility,
which basically means what I'm always
willing to see data if Rogan tomorrow
she comes to me with data showing that
the mechanisms of evolution as an
unstated starting with Darwin are wrong.
Then I would be a dishonest scientist to
not revise my beliefs in light of Joe
Rogan's evidence.
So in other words,
scientists are always open.
It's always provisional knowledge.
It's,
it's only the best that we have now.
Whereas in religion it's revealed truth.
It is true because it is true because
it's in my book because it's true.
So in a sense,
religious people are epistemologically
hottie they're arrogant because nothing
could change their opinions.
Whereas science has changed your
opinions every day.
So in that sense,
I don't think we're both succumbing to
belief systems now.
I'm not necessarily saying that I'm not,
and I'm not equating them,
I'm not saying they're equal,
but it is an odd belief and not
necessarily even belief,
for lack of a better word,
but it's an odd,
it's an odd concept that because we know
that this exists and because we have
some sort of residual trace of an
explosion a long time ago,
you can try and it's mind blowing.
I mean,
I,
I probably just as a layperson in
physics,
uh,
probably one percent of what I see in a
national geographic on physics I can
even remotely understand,
right?
Because it just seems so.
And it's not as though I'm not capable
of complex thought,
but it's just so difficult for human
minds.
You know,
what does it mean?
16 dollars,
billion light years away,
right?
I mean,
for the light to travel for $16,
billion light years,
that's the envelope.
I mean,
how do you understand these kinds of.
It's too big.
And then the concept of life and death
is also luck.
Our physical limitations because we know
that we live and die and we know that
the sun is going to burn out and we know
that life on earth lives and dies and
things,
so we,
we impose these physical restrictions on
the very universe itself when in fact it
might be some constant process of
expanding and contracting.
That's one of the most disturbing ideas
is that the universe is gonna expand
infinitely and then contract infinitely
and then do it all over again.
So that,
I mean,
I don't know if this is even a correct
theory.
I don't know if maybe it's been
disputed,
but I had read once that there was a
theory that the universe contracts to
some insanely infinite position and then
retracts down to the head of a pin
again.
Right.
And then the whole big bang is this
continual process that might take,
you know,
a hundred trillion years or something
insane.
I don't know.
I don't know if you understand one
percent.
I understand zero,
zero,
zero point one.
I actually had this physicist on my
show.
He might be a fun guy to have on your
Uh,
his name is Lee Smolin a,
he's a guy who produced.
The way that I discovered his work is
that I was looking for every possible
field that I could think of where
evolutionary theory has been infused
into field.
Right?
So for example,
in my case,
I apply evolutionary psychology and
consumer behavior.
You could study criminal criminality
from an evolutionary perspective.
You can study medicine.
And so I was trying to come up with a
table that listed all of the various
scientific disciplines where
evolutionary principles have made
headway and the field at the highest
level.
Remember we were talking about middle
world and the cosmos.
He argued that the process of natural
selection operates at the cosmological
level where this grand set of universes
are being selected.
In other words,
in the same way that we select genes,
right?
Some jeans get selected and others die
out.
That that mechanism,
sort of a cosmological natural selection
at the cosmological level.
And so that's how I first this.
It is so mind blowing.
It is so esoteric.
It's so difficult to so nonpalpable that
it,
it borders on taking mushrooms or
psychedelics that that's how mind
blowing.
So you should.
Maybe you should check out our chat on
my show is really cool guy.
You might enjoy them.
Well,
it is fascinating.
We think of how much the universe,
how many possibilities exist in the
universe,
right?
I mean how many different source
systems?
Just hundreds of billions just in this
galaxy.
One of hundreds of billions of gallons.
It's almost like for our little tiny
world,
so when we try to look at it in terms of
the big picture,
we're not capable.
We don't have enough processing power.
We don't have enough hard drive space.
We can't take all of these points of
data and bring them into our head and
consider them,
but it's entirely possible that
everything you see in the world in terms
of competition,
everything you see in the human world in
terms of competition,
natural selection,
and the constant and never ending desire
for innovation,
for novelty,
for new things.
We have this constant desire to improve
upon every single thing that we've ever
done.
No one ever looks at like a car,
I mean,
and says this is the best car ever,
will not be improved upon.
We're done.
We don't need to make cars anymore.
Right?
They always want to come up with
something that has better airbags,
faster,
zero to 60,
more protection for the passenger,
automated controls,
you know you can sit back and sleep
while your car drives you to work.
There's all these things that we just
take for granted,
but they're always moving in the
direction of improvement and you could
do that with life on earth.
You go back to single celled organisms
which become multi celled organisms and
we always look at it like,
oh,
that's just a coincidence and it's
dinosaurs,
and then it becomes mammos and then it
becomes humans.
Then it becomes air plane riding,
cell phone using video,
having.
You know what I mean?
It just gets more and more complex,
but we just,
oh,
that's just coincidence.
Is it?
Or is it moving in this constant state
of improvement until we create an
artificial
being that can accelerate things far,
far faster than our biological
limitations are capable of doing it.
So I'm not sure if this is where you
want to go,
but as you,
as you were describing this sort of
quest for improvement,
one of the,
uh,
one of the threats of that reflects,
or one of the dangers of that reflex is
precisely how totalitarian ideologies
develop where they argued that our
current state of the world is faulty.
And if only you implement our ideology,
the shoe,
it could be communism.
It could be,
it could be perfect.
Then it could be perfect socialism.
Exactly.
So,
so there is a way by which we could
reach that utopia if only you adhere to
our ideology.
So there's a real danger in sort of
succumbing to that.
And by the way,
that's one of the.
I'm reading right now,
a book by William Gardner who might come
on my show.
He's a,
I think a political scientist.
His book is called the great divide
where he actually lays out some of the
sort of fundamental,
foundational differences between
Liberals and conservatives in terms of
their world views and how because of the
starting positions being sold,
different,
having no overlap between them,
the venn diagrams don't overlap.
That's why you ended up speaking over
each other without being able to find
common grounds.
So one of these differences is that an
I,
I described something similar using
different terms.
A lot of the quote,
liberals and progressives view our brain
as being blank slates,
right?
It's infinitely malleable and so if you
see differences between people,
it can't be because there was a starting
point difference.
Michael Jordan was not innately likely
to be better than you in basketball.
There were some environmental conditions
that lead Michael Jordan to become who
he is and not get sad to be the best nba
player ever.
And if only we can find the appropriate
social intervention strategies,
then we could all have equality of
outcomes.
And so that is a faulty understanding of
human nature because human nature,
as you of course,
you know,
it's really an interaction of our
biology and our environment.
But so much of the welfare state is
based on this idea that no,
we need more of your tax money so that
we could implement a social engineering
program so that we could reach that
utopia where we're all equal outcome.
And frankly I think that that's complete
nonsense.
It is fascinating that people seek
comfort in communism and socialism for
that very reason.
Like they almost are trying to slow down
the competition that they can't win.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah,
I see it by the way,
by my university.
So in Canada there's a very sort of
social welfare states and Quebec,
the province where I live is sort of
socialist on welfare,
on steroids.
And so in the context of the
university's,
every,
all of the metrics of reward are removed
so that we can have equality of
outcomes.
And the way that you instantiate that is
through,
uh,
the unions,
right?
So there's a very powerful union that
ensures that all professors are roughly
treated equally because we're all social
ads.
There's a queen bee and then the rest of
us are all equal,
but of course humans are not equal.
Some are smarter,
some work harder,
some are more apathetic,
some are honest,
some are cheaters.
And so this idea of constantly having to
have some external agent managed the
process so that we could all be equal to
me is grotesque.
And it goes back to I think probably our
first conversation you and I had when I
was saying that,
you know,
I would love to eventually come through
southern California because at least in
the United States,
the society has been less progressive
dies by the social welfare idea.
Of course the Democrats are more so than
the Republicans.
But as a general rule,
Canada is basically pure social welfare.
We're all equal.
And of course Justin Trudeau is
certainly trying to push that idea even
more.
He's too handsome.
That's that guy's problem he's trying to
make up for the fact that it's beautiful
and he's trying to be super sweet to
everybody.
That's what's going on up there.
Did you hear about the.
I just put up a clip a few days ago
about the Ahmad.
How their case do you know that is.
No,
actually a few people tweeted,
oh,
please talk to Joe Rogan about this.
Uh,
so all my,
how that is,
uh,
a Muslim guy whose family had become
Canadian citizens,
but the father had taken them away.
I think the Pakistan at one point until
Afghanistan in another.
Uh,
and at one point they were living in
Bali bomb territory.
This is 2002 I think.
And the US military had engaged in some
firefight,
a,
at one point they even lived in the
compound of bin Ladin.
So these were really real apple Pie
Canadian folks.
And all my father who was 15 years old
apparently threw a grenade engaged in a
firefight,
killed one a US soldier,
and I think blind that his second one,
he was taken to Guantanamo Bay as a 15
year old,
spent many years there.
He was a military tribunal.
US Guantanamo tribunals gave him a
symbolic sentence of 40 years.
But it was symbolic in that I think it
was only going to be a h here.
They agreed on a plea deal of eight
years.
Okay.
Then he was extradited to Canada very
quickly after that he was released
because you already served quite a few
years in Guantanamo and then he filed a
lawsuit against the Canadian government
for not having protected his Canadian
charter rights because he was a child
soldier and so on.
And he just settled on a 10 point
$5,000,000 settlement and an official
apology by the Canadian government.
Uh,
and then some,
most people were outraged.
Most Canadians are outraged.
But then you should see the comments and
some of my,
on my youtube channel,
you know,
what kind of pig are you talking to me
that I would not understand that this
was an innocent child soldier who.
Yeah,
because most of us are usually hanging
around when we were 15 and the compound
of the law than,
and lobbing bombs at incoming marines.
You know,
it's a very Canadian apple pie thing to
do.
So again,
the reflex is not to be outraged at my
taxpayers are funding this guy now in a
10 point $5,000,000 settlement.
I'm a pig.
I'm a racist pig for not understanding
that this was just an innocent child
soldier at the wrong place at the wrong
time.
Okay,
let's look at two different things.
One,
the amount of money they gave him.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy that your tax dollars
go to that,
but let's look at the 15 year old kid,
right?
What do you expect and what could
possibly be done to dissuade him from
following this path?
He's living in bin Laden's compound.
You're talking about someone who's
vulnerable to ideology.
Fifty year old men are vulnerable to
ideology.
What about a 15 year old child?
Like I don't know how much blame you can
put on a kid now when it comes to
throwing a bomb at someone and taking
the life of another human being.
Well,
there's gotta be a lot of circumstances
involved in that.
I would like to know what they are
before I think about any judgment
whatsoever because I don't know.
Were they shooting at him?
Were they shooting at someone he knew
someone who knew getting murdered by a
US soldier.
Was he actively engaged in some sort of
military training and considering
becoming,
becoming a militant?
I don't know.
10 is a baby.
I mean yes and no.
Right?
I mean you can.
You can drive a car at 16 and Quebec.
You can start driving drivers.
Yeah.
At 15.
Is that what is my team?
Yeah,
my,
my mother and father,
my mother,
my father was 19.
My mother was almost 16 when they got
married.
So you can procreate and have a child
that you don't understand the.
Yeah,
but let's be real about physiologically
your frontal cortex isn't even formed
until you're 25.
When you're 15 years old,
you're not capable of making like
especially living in a war zone,
you're not capable of making moral and
ethical judgements above and beyond the
ideology that you're being raised.
Fair enough.
I mean,
I,
I agree that most of us in that
situation may not have been able to
extricate ourselves from that.
And what I'm going to say next doesn't
necessarily support the outrage,
but it gives it greater context.
He does come from a family if you later,
if you check when we get off the air,
the sort of the,
the cues of this family,
they don't seem as though they are
assimilating very nicely within Canadian
value system.
In other words,
for most Canadians,
the reflex of taking this guy who seems
to be quite resistant to liberty and
modernity freedoms
and rewarding him with 10 point
$5,000,000,
by the way,
this 10 point five Canadian.
So it's probably $30 American at this
point.
The doctor thought we.
You guys were real similar.
We were a few years ago.
We were at par and I think now we're at
one point three.
So we're about 20,
25,
30 percent less than you.
So that's how it was when I was a.
When I first used to go up to Montreal,
like in the nineties at the par or,
or different.
Different the way it is.
So you're saying now the American dollar
went far longer up there.
That's right,
yeah.
It's,
it's heading back towards that now and
not at,
not not to the worst.
The worst I've ever seen.
It was when we lived in California in
2001 to 2003.
At one point it was points 64 or 65.
Now it's at about point 75,
so it's not the worst that it's ever
been,
but we're heading in that direction.
But since we're talking about kind of
the,
maybe you'd like to talk about a,
and I know that you've had Jordan
Peterson on.
Did you follow both of our respective,
uh,
testimonies in front of the Canadian
Senate regarding Bill 16 and you know,
I've read a lot of Jordan stuff on that.
I've seen him speak a lot and I've seen,
I saw that one conversation that he had
on television in Canada with some person
who is a professor in gender studies who
is ambiguously sexual.
I don't know what they are,
whether it's a guy or a girl or a
transgender woman to man,
this is what it seemed to be,
right?
Yes.
And the one who was saying that there's
no that gender,
there was no biological difference
between men and women.
Yes.
Which is just fucking horseshit.
I mean that is just like one plus one is
not too.
I mean it really is.
There's obviously a broad spectrum of
variation and both sexes and they kind
of coalesce in the middle somewhere with
some.
Well,
what's amazing is that I've been
fighting this battle and academia
precisely because of what I do,
which is introduce evolutionary
psychology and the social sciences.
So these types of conversations,
these ludicrous conversations I've been
experiencing them for for much of my
scientific career.
What's extraordinary at this point is
that some of this nonsense is now
becoming law in Canada.
So to kind of give you the background to
what happened.
So I was invited both speaking by the
Canadian Senate,
then also to give a talk in front of
parliament on Parliament Hill,
but the Canadian Senate,
the part was built [inaudible],
which is a bill that seeks to
incorporate gender identity and gender
expression under the rubric of hate
crimes.
Right?
So in the same way that I can
discriminate against you for your
religion or your race or your ethnicity,
I can't discriminate against you because
of your gender identity or gender
expression,
because then that would be a hate crime.
And so I appeared in front of the
Canadian Senate to simply say that while
of course everybody's person who should
be respected and we're all equal under
the law,
the manner by which the bill was a
table,
the
way it was written,
it was so vague as as it for it to be
dangerous.
And so I gave examples.
So let me just mentioned a few here for
your viewers.
So I said,
look,
Harvard University,
their lgbtq office,
came out with a pamphlet that said that
the idea of promulgating,
and I'm going to quote fixed binaries
and biological essentialism,
close quote,
fixed binaries,
means male,
female,
biological,
essentialism,
is to argue that anything is biological.
So the idea of a gay thing,
fixed binaries and biological
essentialism is a form of transphobic,
systemic violence.
This is not violence.
Violence is,
and it's not metaphorical.
It's not allegorical.
It's not bad.
I mean violence in quotes,
it is a form of Transphobia,
but specifically systemic violence,
transphobia know,
how do they define violence because
there's a very specific definition of
violence.
While I don't know how they defined it
in the general sense,
I think it's the desire to come up with
ever broadening definitions of violence
so that any,
any trans question that you commit could
fit under that rubric.
Even microaggression,
microaggression is a form of violence,
right?
So,
so then I went in front of the Canadian
Senate.
Not,
I'm not you,
you could watch this later.
Uh,
it's on my channel.
I said,
look,
every single thing that I teach in my
courses would constitute transphobic
systemic violence based on that sort of
standard,
right?
It sound scientific data.
Exactly.
So if I get up and say,
here is how sexual selection works,
right?
Sexual selection is the mechanism that
explains how sex specific traits evolve.
Well,
sex specific traits evolve.
You recognize that there is male and
there's female.
Here's why.
Human males are likely to have been
sexually selected to be more risk
takers.
Right?
Well,
by engaging in that conversation,
I would be promulgating fixed binaries
and biological essentialism,
transphobic,
transphobic violence because a
transgendered student can come up to me
and say,
look,
professor,
you've thought your core,
I've listened to your course 13 weeks.
You talked about evolve mating
preferences on.
Not once did you talk about the
non-gender,
the non binary,
that gender fluid,
the other kid,
and so on.
Uh,
that's marginalized me.
That's excluded me.
Uh,
you're being biased,
you're being prejudicial.
So I tried to argue that most of the
liberal senators either laughed and
scoffed.
One of them accused me of being pro
genocide.
This is on record and the Canadian
Senate.
So a scientist.
What's this person's name?
I think Senator Joel,
but I,
I started pushing the which has now
become maybe a,
an internet.
You have a conversation with them and we
did it in there.
So we,
the conversation we had was promoting
genocide.
Someone said,
well,
how do you respond to that when someone
says that?
So that my response,
which you could,
I'm paraphrasing,
he says,
well,
I'm not sure that given the fact that I
escape execution in Lebanon because of
my Jewish heritage,
that I need to be lectured about a
genocide,
and that sort of took them back.
Now apparently later and I didn't see
this apparently later,
he wanted to retract some of these
comments and apologize for them.
I don't know if you are not.
How did they justify genocide?
Like what?
That's what happens when you have your
brain parenthesized by ostrich parasitic
syndrome.
How does,
how is it okay to study all of these
behavior patterns in aunts and monkeys
and dogs and what have you,
but you can't with human beings because
if you do with human being somehow or
another,
anything that you find about generalized
behavior patterns or specific sexual
preferences that somehow or another
marginalizes or in some way diminishes
how another person is living their life
to the point where it becomes violence.
So there's actually a term for what you
just asked.
It's called the human reticence effect
and simply put,
a lot of people are perfectly happy to
use evolutionary arguments to explain
the behavior of the salamander,
the Hyena,
the mosquito,
the dog,
but if you use the exact same
evolutionary principle to explain human
phenomena,
then suddenly it's no go.
Why is that?
Do you think?
It's because we're aspiring to something
better.
I think it's because people succumb to
wrongly,
so to the idea of biological
determinism,
they think that if you.
If you call up and explaining a
phenomenon,
a biological principle,
that means you are doing to your
biology.
It's a fatalistic thing,
which of course is nonsense because
there's no such thing as biological
determinism because most of the things
that are triggered by our biology have
to be triggered by interacting with the
environment.
Right?
Genes are turned on or off as a function
of environmental inputs and outputs,
so the idea of biological determinism is
false worry.
Much of what we do,
it's called the interaction as
viewpoint.
Much of who we are as an interaction of
our genes and our environments,
but for most people there is something
vulgar about reducing the richness of
the human condition to our biology.
It just feels wrong.
This explains the behavior of the Hyena,
but we are above that.
We are cultural animals.
We are prone to conditioning and
socialization and higher order
cognition.
So you could even take evolutionary
biologists.
So these are people who are trained in
evolutionary biology.
They will commit this error.
I mean that's breathtaking,
right?
So the classic example is a guy who is
otherwise an utter buffoon.
His name is Ed Meyers,
a fifth through eighth academic.
And I say this because not to denigrate
him,
but by zed.
That's the letter z
Canadian.
So pz Myers in his claim to fame is he's
got a very,
and hats off to him.
He's got an incredibly popular
scientific,
a blog called fire wrangler,
which you know,
gets $100,
million views or something.
So he's done very well for himself,
but he's the guy who is perfectly happy
to use evolutionary principles to
explain the behavior of the mating
behavior.
Of the salamander,
but if I come along as an evolutionary
psychologist and use the exact same
principle,
the exact same logical structure to
explain human behavior,
well,
what's this guy doing with this bullshit
evolutionary psychology stuff that's not
set that pseudo science right,
and the the reflex he has that is
because to somehow explain it for the
salamander,
make sense?
It's national geographic,
but humans,
they don't.
They're not prone to biology and I'll
just give you two other examples.
Stephen Jay Gould,
Richard Lewington,
who were very,
very famous.
Harvard evolutionists also despised
evolutionary psychology,
but for other reasons they were avowed
Marxists.
They came sort of from the hippie
generation is of the market.
They're probably about 20 years older
than me.
Well,
one of the announced passed away,
Stephen Jay Gould is that,
but they were guys who thought that if
evolutionary psychology is right,
then they're Marxists.
Bullshit ideologies would be wrong.
So they were strong anti evolutionary
psychology folks,
even though all of their training
suggested that they should be for it.
So they are the guys,
by the way,
who used to Eo Wilson I mentioned
earlier.
So eo Wilson.
The social ads guy wrote a book called a
sociobiology in 1975 where he explained
how evolutionary theory could explain
behavior across all sorts of animals.
Everybody was happy with the book and
one of the last chapters,
he applies all these principles to the
human condition.
He became persona non grata.
He became a Nazi.
He couldn't go anywhere to give a talk
without being shouted down.
Not unlike how you're seeing Milo today
being shouted down.
Well,
Eo Wilson went through those culture
wars 30 years ago because evolutionary
psychology was attacking the pet
political ideologies of his colleagues
at Harvard.
I don't know if Milo's a valid
comparison.
I think Jordan Peterson better
Fair enough.
Because Milo is obviously a provocateur,
1 trillion on purpose.
What do you put tea?
Instead of pointing the finger at
individuals?
I wouldn't like to try to figure out.
Obviously we're not going to,
but let's discuss it.
Sure.
What?
What is the motivation?
Why do people resist these ideas of
looking at the data of human interaction
and genetics and sexual preference?
Why do they resist examining these
factors?
Like what is it about and what is it
about people that like that guy that
you're talking about that wants to point
at you for examining these factors and
call you horrific names and just for
looking at actual provable data data
that you can mean you could show it,
you
could do.
It's reviewed.
You can what?
What is?
What's the motivation is it's ultimately
ego driven.
So in the case of those Harvard folks,
they are committed Marxists,
right?
If evolutionary psychology is right,
therefore my pet political ideology is
wrong,
therefore I have to shoot it.
That's one example.
Let's,
let's do a.
suppose I am a overweight woman.
Okay,
and I don't.
I don't get much action on the mating
market.
One of two things can happen.
I could either believe that there is an
evolved preference that men have for
certain universal standards of beauty.
Or I could go for the much more a
comforting message,
which is that these beauty standards are
arbitrary,
sexist,
patriarchal standards,
and if only men would stop being shallow
and buying into these Hollywood images
than myself,
this beautiful 800 pound woman would be
getting all the action in the world.
So it's nothing wrong with me.
It's that there are outside forces that
are causing these arbitrary preferences
to arise.
Right?
Naomi Wolf wrote a book and the early
nineties,
uh,
the beauty myth that sold millions of
copies where she argued that there is no
such thing as universal standards of
beauty.
It's all a beauty myth.
It's the patriarchy that imposes these
beauty myths on women to attack their
sense of self.
Well,
if I'm a woman who doesn't score well,
even if I'm,
if I'm a man,
for example,
and we know that women prefer men of
high status,
well,
I could do one of two things.
I could get out there and shake my butt
and get the status right Joe Rogan.
Nobody gave him all this stuff that you
have.
You have to work hard for all your
success so that you could then hopefully
do well on the mating market,
uh,
or I could say,
you know what,
these are all arbitrary standards.
I mean,
and adjust world.
My being a lazy,
apathetic Beta male would just be as
worthy of love.
And so I think ultimately there is an
element to biological based explanations
that's unhopeful to most people,
right?
The idea that we could all be anything
is a lot more hopeful and the idea that
we could all be anything unconstrained
by biology only exists in the recesses
of ideologues.
The world is not made up like that.
Beautiful.
People are more symmetric.
Now.
That doesn't mean that if you're not
symmetric,
you're doomed to a life of celibacy.
But no,
the fact that Brad Pitt Brad Pitt is,
is considered handsome because he
exhibits certain cues that women all
around the world agree are beautiful.
So to answer your question,
there is something very non hopeful
about buying.
The idea that we are biological beings.
It's a lot more comforting to know we
are infinitely malleable and filthy
social bubble because
then any of us could be anything given
the right conditions.
I could be the next lionelle messy
that's hopeful and therefore I'd like to
subscribe to that.
I think there's absolutely something to
what you're saying,
but I think there's also this very
strange and vague possibility that we
are aspiring to a higher standard
because we recognize that human beings
are evolving and that we're moving into
some strange place where we're.
We're no longer just creatures of flesh
and that this need to put people on
this.
Even playing field is.
This is a part of this aspiration.
I definitely think there's these
influences and I definitely think there
are these.
There's a lot of people that look at
beautiful people and they get upset.
I mean there's a.
there's a way that they do it where they
feel that they're justified in being
prejudice.
Like they can see a guy like the rock
for example,
who's as big,
handsome man as big burly man and they
think that guy's a fucking idiot.
Immediately me and while that guy
probably reads a lot,
he's probably smart as hell,
right,
and he's obviously very ambitious so he
can control his mind.
Charismatic,
he's very disciplined.
He controls his mind far better than a
lot of overweight people that would
criticize him and call him a fool,
but meanwhile they let their body rot to
the state of decay,
which is not an intellectual thing to do
if you're looking at your body and like
a as a finite resource and how do you
manage that resource?
Well,
very poorly for eating,
ring dings,
drinking fucking soda and smoking
cigarettes and then talking about the
rock being an idiot.
Right?
I mean that's.
These are obviously strom and
exemptions,
but I wonder if what we're doing with
what's going on in Canada and this,
this liberal social justice warrior
approach to everybody being equal and if
they're not,
let's try to make them equal and if
there's anybody that's superior to try
to push them down and bring the Brown
people up and I wonder if we're trying
to achieve some sort of equilibrium,
some sort of balance,
some sort of,
some sort of state where we're no longer
just monkeys were no longer just
creatures of,
you know,
I want to fuck her because she's got big
tits.
These are base ideas.
These are base instincts that it's fine
if we observe them in Benobos,
but we don't want to see them in Harvard
educated kids.
Right?
So the male gaze becomes problematic,
right?
A man staring at a woman becomes a
microaggression.
Meanwhile,
she's wearing almost nothing.
She's got a short skirt on and painted
toes and you want to look.
You can't help yourself.
The jeans come firing up.
You must suppress those because we were
eventually moving past the flesh and you
are of the new generation.
The new generation that will someday be
neutered and there'll be some non binary
expression of your humanity that exists
as an Avatar and some virtual reality
world that you'll be forced to subscribe
to when you,
when you joined Yale,
but by the way,
that's when you talk about the male
gaze.
I'm not sure if we've discussed this on
this show before,
but it's precisely this type of thinking
that causes the western feminists to
view the Burka is liberating and the
bikini as a patriarchal oppression.
It's.
It's exactly that,
right?
The to the extent that the male gaze as
a form of visual rape,
right,
and that should be condemned.
That should be stopped because it is a
type of assault in quotes,
right?
The Burka.
By removing that male gaze becomes
liberating.
Now,
this is not an argument that I'm making
up.
This is,
I've heard this argument.
On the other hand,
when a woman wears the Brazilian a Thong
and you and I look at her and have the
exact same predictable response that
most men would have because it's an
evolved response.
Well,
that's,
that's bad because we are part of the
Patriarchy and we are succumbing to this
rape urge,
right?
So this is so when I talk about ostrich
parasitic syndrome,
I don't just use it as a metaphor,
it's genuinely the case that people's
minds are becoming infected with such
garbage that they're incapable to
rationalize,
to think would reason.
And that's what I ended up doing most of
the time.
That's what Jordan Peterson ends up
doing most of the time,
which is we are committed to truth
unencumbered by political correctness.
Earlier you were saying,
what would be some,
you know,
how can we get ourselves out of
succumbing to this tribalism and so on.
I think the only way you could do it,
and I'm not saying that anybody can
reach that level,
is to simply be dedicated to the pursuit
of truth.
When I was on Sam Harris Show,
uh,
you know,
earlier this year,
about six,
seven months ago,
he asked me,
is there any,
a research question that you would not
tackle in your,
in your,
in your scientific career that is too
taboo?
And my answer was no.
Right?
As long as you address the question
honestly and objectively,
there is nothing that should be off
limits,
right?
Because then it becomes very easy to
say,
well,
sex differences,
we shouldn't study that because then it
will marginalize one sex or the other
race differences.
We shouldn't study them for the same
reason.
So on.
That becomes forbidden knowledge.
No,
the highest ideal that any honest person
should pursue is the pursuit of truth
and certainly an intellectual.
So No,
don't be encumbered by political
correctness.
Just pursue the truth.
And I think one of the reasons for that
Jordan Peterson's message and my message
has resonated now with a lot of people
is because at least they see that we are
ascribing to that ideal to the best of
our abilities.
What if that truth hurts your feelings?
Fuck you're feeling.
Oh,
I'm triggered.
I believe I used the f word was this
podcast.
I was an effect on people.
Yeah,
I think it's,
um,
you know,
it's a bunch of different things going
on all at once and
there's obviously some tribalism going
on even amongst these social justice
warriors.
He's a virtue signaling people who are
trying to get as much credit as much
social justice warrior street credit as
they can,
like what happened with Bret Weinstein
up in Evergreen college and when I had
him on,
I just read some recent thing where
they're doubling down on their hate of
him and you know,
they,
they're,
they're accusing him of all of this by
simply going on the Tucker Carlson show.
Now,
here's what's fascinating.
Huffington post,
which is a really left leaning
establishment,
right?
I mean if any website is left leaning,
it's Huffington Post.
I mean I think they have some great
articles.
Don't get me wrong.
It's not like I'm not critical of all
their stuff,
but it's very left leaning,
like openly regard.
They had a piece breaking down how
preposterous these students are and the
faculty and the president and what they
have done to Bret Weinstein and
criticized each step of it by showing a
transcription of his conversation on the
Tucker Carlson show,
which lasted like five minutes I think.
And you know,
they called Tucker Carlson alt right.
Okay.
I don't know.
You redefining outright now,
by the way,
I've been called.
All right.
Dave Rubin and I are leaders of the
ultra.
That's amazing.
We're leaders.
We the actual leaders of the alt right.
I wrote a tweet about this,
like the fact that they can call Dave
Rubin,
who is a gay man who's married to a man
who used to be on the young Turks who's
Jewish,
who is Jewish and I mean I guess I
called him a progressive,
but it progressive in the idea that he,
he wants progress.
I mean the real broad term of
progressive progress,
meaning equality for all but honest,
honest about the approach,
but I would consider him probably more
of a libertarian bent if you wanted to
get like political,
which I guess I'm sort of in this sort
of progressive slash libertarian left
leaning thing,
but I also believe in a lot of right
things as well.
Like,
you know,
the.
I think that competition is probably
ultimately good.
Right?
And I think that blaming other people
for your lack of success is really easy
and it's something that people do all
the time.
But when you do that,
if you look at things in that way,
then you're diminishing the struggles
that downtrodden people and minorities
and the oppressed and all these
different,
uh,
you know,
small groups that have been somehow
another marginalized there.
You're diminishing their struggle,
which is absolutely not the case.
But there have been people that have
emerged from those groups and done
amazing things.
But Oh,
those are outliers and you can't hold
people up to the standards of those
outliers.
And you know,
the real problem is that the is stacked
in the favor of these white men who
experienced white privilege.
And what we really need to do is squash
white men.
By the way,
I have,
I have a theory about all this stuff.
Well,
this.
So I called it collective Munchhausen.
Oh,
you've said this before.
Please go.
Go again though.
I'd like this to stand alone.
Thank you.
So remember how earlier I said that the
highest ideal should be the pursuit of
the truth.
Yeah.
So the currency that I operate in is
pursuing truth.
Wherever that leads me a banker cares
about the bottom line.
How much money,
how many Zeros there are in his bank,
right?
And my case.
It's truth.
Now in the social justice warriors
currency,
it's how much eagle strokes he or she
gets by proclaiming unique victimhood
status.
Now,
why do I call this collective
Munchhausen?
So in 2010,
I had published a paper in a medical
journal where I was looking at a
specific form of Munchhausen Syndrome as
a psychiatric condition where someone
feigns illness to get attention,
to get empathy,
to get sympathy.
It's a real psychiatric condition.
I know a lady who's got it.
Is that right?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
I later I will write a Munchausen
Syndrome by proxy is a different
situation where you try to get your ego
stroked by harming someone else and then
getting the rewards.
So what does that mean?
You are,
for example,
at biological mother who,
who has this condition,
you will harm your child,
your biological child,
so that then you could take him to the
hospital and people say,
Oh,
poor you,
you've got a sick alien child and so on.
And then you get your your or orgiastic
orgasmic strokes by getting that
attention and that empathy,
right?
Or You could do it if you have a pet or
sometimes with elderly parents,
but usually it's your biological child.
So I was writing a paper trying to
explain this from an evolutionary
perspective,
how this pathology could arise,
and so that's how the psychiatric
syndrome wasn't in my radar.
And then as I started seeing all these
social justice warriors navigating the
world through a game of oppression,
Olympics,
where the highest goal you can achieve
is to be declared the winner of the
oppression Olympics game,
right?
It's not the pursuit of truth.
It's not making the most money.
It's can I be anointed as the guy with
the greatest.
And I call this collective Munchhausen
because it becomes a form of
Munchhausen,
but at the collective level.
Right?
Let me give you another example as
voting for Donald Trump.
When Donald Trump won the election,
just on my facebook page,
private personal facebook page,
I would see people outdoing each other
almost as if it were satirical in terms
of their collective Munchausen.
I am a brown woman who was attending
this university now that Donald Trump
has won.
I'm afraid to go to classes.
I mean,
just think about how outrageous that
sounds.
I mean you may like or dislike Donald
Trump.
Do you genuinely believe that your
ability to take classes and your
bullshit college and main is going to be
affected?
You're going to experience personal
safety because Donald Trump is setting
up roadblocks so that he could create
internment camps for all women of color
so that they get gang raped.
What is the fear that you have that you
are literally right,
but they're testifying they're
testifying to and so it becomes this
collective psychosis where the way that
I win is by demonstrating that I am the
biggest victim,
and so that's what social justice
warriors do,
is that they have to win that game.
And so there is no.
So the Bret Weinstein example is those
guys seeking to win those Olympics.
How dare you say that?
You could come on campus.
Don't you know what kinds of victims we
are and so on.
It's,
it's a,
it's a complete departure from reason.
It's grotesque.
It's a psychiatric condition,
it's,
it's weird
prevalent.
It is though,
and how it's almost one of those things
that you as a professor are not really
allowed to discuss with the people that
are exhibiting that behavior because
then you're diminishing their fear,
right?
You're diminishing or marginalizing
their,
their own personal issues that they feel
that they have.
Except except because I always can pull
out my victimology card which usually
outranks all of them because they're
screaming while sitting at Wellesley
paying $60,000 that they are
marginalized.
Whereas I say I'm not sure if I can be
sympathetic because let me tell you my
personal history.
Well that's what,
yeah.
Did with that guy and I'm in the meeting
when he accused you of genocide.
He's not.
You've hit them with braces.
Exactly.
Like suck it stupid.
And so now
by the way,
sit.
The only way I could improve my score as
I have jokingly said,
is if I self identify as a woman,
I'm transgendered.
Would you shave though?
If you self identified as a woman,
why do you have to assume the appearance
of a woman?
I mean,
if really appearances don't matter.
Exactly.
I mean if,
if a woman with a penis.
Well yeah,
I mean this whole idea that beauty
standards are bullshit and that are
constructed by the patriarchy.
Why can't you grow a big old Santa
Claus?
Beard steel.
Still identify with a woman.
I'm,
I'm with you.
Why can't you?
Well,
let's,
let's set the trend.
But where do we draw the line though?
Because I have no problem with someone
identifying as a woman.
If you want to be a woman,
that's fine.
I don't care.
But.
Well,
where.
Where do we draw the line though?
Where are you allowed?
Where are you?
How,
how out there can you get before I'm
allowed to go.
Well,
that guy might be fucking crazy.
Have you heard about this new?
There's this new,
I think called I think cis sexism.
Have you heard this?
No,
I think I covered it in one of my sad
truth.
It's
basically the idea that,
so you,
you,
you're a heterosexual male and CIS
gendered,
right?
Which is not real.
That's not a real expression,
but it is real.
But we'll all expressions are created by
humans,
right?
So very true.
Some humans,
except so you and I wish to mate with
women,
hence we are heterosexual.
Do we?
Okay.
Right now,
stay with me now at by you restricting
your preference to this old antiquated
term of women,
meaning that they have vaginas.
You're actually engaging in a form of
CIS,
CIS sexism because there are women who
have nine inch penises who should also
be privy to your attention.
So by you saying,
yes,
I'm attracted to women,
but only the women that are cis
gendered,
that have female genitalia,
that's a form of CIS sexism.
This idea is not being promulgated.
So you even saying that you have a
heterosexual orientation towards
biological women as a form of
Transphobia,
not unlike by the way.
Here's another example of racialism.
Have you heard of this?
I said yes.
Okay.
I love this idea.
Isn't it fantastic?
It's wonderful.
So how far can we take this?
Like how we far?
Okay.
So you think that you think the fulcrum
is not going to start swinging the other
way at some point?
For sure it will.
And it has,
and I think that's one of the reasons
why Donald Trump got into office,
is people are so upset with political
correctness,
they went with the exact opposite,
which is buffoonery outrageous
braggadocious male buffoonery.
I mean,
that's really what it is.
he's a braggadocious buffoon and in a
lot of respects,
especially the way he talks about his
ratings and ones talks about himself in
the third person,
you know,
like he was describing Kanye west and
Kanye loves trump mean,
could you imagine saying that about
yourself and describing yourself in
third person,
but a famous person loving you.
Right?
It's so bizarre.
You know,
a lot of people who follow me think that
I joked that,
that they think that I have these trump
posters in my room and you know,
he's my big hero,
which of course he's not.
And by the way,
I'm Canadian,
so I truly don't have a dog in this
fight.
The reason why they think that is
because I offered prior to the election
being done,
I offered some compelling reasons,
psychological reasons why people might
vote for Donald Trump.
So most famously,
perhaps in my chat with Sam Harris,
I explained the psychological mechanisms
that could lead to otherwise perfectly
reasonable people to vote for trump,
simply proposing these was complete
unacceptable.
I'm sure you're aware of what's going on
with Scott Adams and Scott Adams is lost
millions of dollars for simply stating
that he believes that Donald trump
is a very persuasive person and
correctly predicting that that power of
persuasion would allow him to win the
presidency.
He doesn't even vote.
Scott Adams says,
because he talked so much about
politics,
he does not want to have a dog in the
fight,
so he doesn't vote.
He told me that on the podcast.
And so people think that he's a trump
supporter.
He's like,
I'm absolutely not a trump supporter.
He goes,
I'm analyzing the human beings.
Exactly.
And so here's.
So just to kind of repeat what I told
Sam.
So they are different decision rules
that one can use when they're making a
choice between different competing
alternative.
So for example,
if you're choosing between cars,
each car is defined by many attributes,
right?
It's gas efficiency,
it's the power of its engine.
It's price and so on and so there are
different ways that I could apply a
decision rule and choosing between car
a,
car b,
so here's one rule I could look at,
take all the attributes,
put them together,
multiply them by the importance weight
of each attribute,
and pick the best product,
so using that decision rule,
maybe Hillary Clinton would have won
because maybe if you put all the
attributes together,
she ends up scoring higher than Donald
Trump,
but here's another the decision rule.
It's called the lexical graphic rule.
Lexical graphical rule basically says,
I simply look at my most important
attribute.
What's the attribute that I care most
when I'm making the choice within this
category,
and I simply choose the alternative that
scores higher on that most important
attribute.
So for example,
if it were a cars,
I only care about the power of the
engine,
so I choose car a because it has a
stronger power engine,
right?
And the case of Donald Trump versus
Hillary Clinton.
Suppose that my lexical graphic rule is
I care only about the position on
immigration.
That's my decision.
That's the only thing I look at.
Well,
it's very reasonable for people to think
that Donald trump had a more
conservative view on immigration than
Hillary Clinton.
So if I use that decision rule,
that psychological rule,
I would choose Donald Trump.
It wouldn't make me a guy who is
sleeping with my sister and I'm a tooth
tooth toothless sky and Arkansas and a
hick.
It simply means that I'm using a
particular decision rule that causes me
to choose Donald Trump over Hillary
Clinton.
So again,
all I did,
not unlike what Scott Adams did his own
way,
his offer,
the different psychological processes by
which a very reasonable person can end
up choosing Donald trump rather than
Hillary Clinton.
And it's unbelievable.
The kind of flack I got.
It was crazy because it's,
it's
your absolute area of expertise.
I mean,
it's what your education is it.
It's what you teach.
Exactly.
It's so strange that if it doesn't jive
with people's belief systems,
they get upset at you for teaching
something that's science.
Right?
Well,
I call this by the way,
the,
the.
I used to love.
You got sad,
but roof.
So I used to love you got sat,
but trump,
I hate you,
but I just love saying that though.
They used to stay,
love saying that they love to try to
instill a seed of regret.
Not just criticism but regret because
it's more painful,
right?
Like to say,
I just think you're a fool.
It's like,
all right,
well fuck you.
You're not my fan.
I'm not into you.
What's the number one source of flack
that you receive from your gigantic fan
base?
Oh,
the one issue that triggers the most
animal to you.
Boy,
I don't know.
To me like personally,
you know,
Joel,
I think you're a great guy,
but my God,
you're such an idiot because of x.
what's x?
There's so many things we did.
We did a three hour podcasts just to
name them all.
I get a lot of facts wrong.
A lot of things I remember incorrectly
because a lot of these free form
conversations,
like we're having a.
it's not planned out.
The subjects aren't planned out in
particular,
like the divergent paths that we take.
Sometimes we'll go down a path and I'll
go to that.
What was that story about that thing,
and I'll get that shit wrong all the
time because there's just,
I mean,
as good as my memory is and it's pretty
good,
there's just a certain amount of data
that you could instantaneously call up
to the.
I mean if you ask me questions about
certain things that are in my constant
day to day existence,
like maybe perhaps standup comedy or
martial arts,
I can,
I can give you a staggering amount of
information off the top of my head,
but there's a lot of stuff that,
you know,
we talk about in these podcasts.
It's just people say,
well,
you should have prepared for it.
Well,
I didn't know we're going to talk about
it because it's no,
it's one of the things that makes the
conversation so interesting.
So in that sense I'm giving myself would
get out of jail free pass.
But um,
I dunno.
I mean getting things wrong is probably
the big one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Talking over people,
being a meathead,
all those things I'm guilty of.
I think probably the number one thing
for me over the past few months has been
this trump thing where people simply
can't understand.
They think I'm his waterboy,
which of course I'm not,
but I'm simply saying,
look,
very,
very reasonable.
People could have converged to a trump
decision,
a vote,
but don't you think that's like one of
those 140 character criticisms?
Like it's really like I've been called a
trump supporter.
I'm 100 percent not,
but because of the fact that it's a
cruel thing to say to someone,
yeah,
still loving trump.
No,
you fucking idiot.
Like loving trump.
Right?
What am I gonna have a seven minute long
bit about him in my act,
like loving them.
Like what are you talking about it?
But it doesn't matter because by saying
that they could diminish you.
Oh,
you're a racist,
you know?
Oh,
you're a sexist,
right?
You know,
Oh,
you're like the.
One of the craziest ones is someone.
If someone gets unfairly or unjustly or
inaccurately accused of rape,
right?
Immediately that person's a rapist and
they did it and it is incredibly
difficult to exonerate yourself from
that and people that had been accused of
rape.
I mean not people like bill cosby.
We get accused of it 50 fucking times or
something crazy,
but I've known people that were accused
of rape and it was all a lie and they
were.
It was done by an ex and it was just
someone who is a scorned lover
and it was angry and they wanted to cast
the worst possible light on this person
in order to be.
Give them some tastes of the pain that
they feel from rejection or from
whatever reason.
And this is not uncommon.
I mean I don't know what the statistics
are as far as a false rape accusations
versus actual rape versus people who
were raped who don't talk about it,
but either one does not invalidate the
other.
By saying that a lot of women actually
have been raped,
which neither you nor I would ever argue
with.
Of course,
and it's a horrible crime and it's a
terrible fucking thing to do to a person
to take away their humanity in that way.
That does not.
That does not somehow or another make it
okay.
That people have false rape accusations.
No,
that's a horrific thing to.
I mean we can quantify what's worse or
what's better,
you know,
and I think we would all agree that it's
probably worse to be physically raped
than it is to be accused of rape when
you didn't do it,
but they're both gross.
But you have these things that I've
actually written about this.
Do you think that the punishments for
false accusations of rape are too lax?
Because I do.
I think that they don't know what they
are,
but I would say that they should be
pretty horrific,
right?
Almost to the.
Almost the same amount of what he would
have spent in prison.
Yeah,
I think maybe like 70 percent I think.
I think false rape accusations,
especially if you like really chase it
down and try to give this person locked
up.
I mean there's so much wrong with that.
It might be like 70 percent of rape,
70 percent,
meaning like 70 percent.
That's bad.
I shouldn't say a number.
I don't think it's as bad as physically
raping someone,
but it's in the neighborhood.
But I mean think of it this way.
Not to get too philosophical everyday
that a guy spends in prison as a falsely
accused rapist while you,
the woman who falsely accused him is
sitting in your house.
I mean you are a quote committing the
crime every day of his life,
every everyday that you don't step
forward,
punishing,
right?
Yeah.
I mean again,
not to diminish that one act of rape,
but you are raping this guy
metaphorically every if not literally
because he probably is going to be raped
in prison for having that accusation on
top of his head.
Right?
Because that's a targeted person and
positive person,
so in a sense you're almost as
diabolical as a true rapist because you
are living with that false information
and everyday you're going to buy your
tomatoes and groceries.
Unencumbered by the fact that there is a
guy sitting in prison who was probably
passing some very ugly moments because
you are unwilling to correct the wrong
that you've done,
so I think it's a pretty diabolical
person who does that.
It's a definitely.
It's definitely a diabolical person.
The problem is whenever you bring up
this diabolical person,
you automatically get lumped in with
someone who has some sort of an enabler,
some cis gendered male
privileged piece of shit.
It doesn't care about actual rape
victims because you're more concerned
with men who get falsely accused of
rape.
It's just another thing.
It's not.
It's not diminishing the actual crime of
rape,
which is one of the worst things in the
world next to murder.
It's just a horrific,
terrifying aspect of human beings that
we're even capable of doing that,
but it doesn't mean that false rape
accusations aren't also a horrific
aspect of being a person.
There's just a lot of shitty behavior
that people exhibit and as soon as we
lock ourselves into these,
these little groups that will always
blindly support.
Like I have this bit I've been doing
lately about a bumper sticker.
I saw a girl's car,
it said girls kick ass.
Like you imagine if a guy had a bumper
sticker that said boys kick ass.
It's so you're signing off on $160
million people.
That's so crazy.
But it's one of those things where we'll
allow that because we all agree that
women have a harder go of it in this
country in particular and other
countries far more so.
Right.
And we could go back to ideology for the
reasons for that.
What we're talking to
about earlier,
by the way,
speaking of rape,
I don't,
I don't think we've mentioned this.
Everyone on this show,
a two of my colleagues,
one of whom I know.
Well,
the other one,
not so much if at all,
wrote a book around 2000 or 2002,
offering an adaptive evolutionary
explanation for rape he had.
There Ya go.
You don't need to hear anything more
than that.
So.
Yeah,
exactly.
So actually I'll tell you their names.
So Randy Thornhill,
who's a very,
very serious scientists,
and Craig Palmer,
they wrote a book,
I think it was in 2000 now.
They weren't of course,
justifying rape,
condoning it.
They were saying,
look,
if you wish to understand rape,
then you better have a good scientific
basis for why it happens,
and therefore they offered something
adaptive argument.
Which by the way,
that's one of the main things that
people will hate.
Evolution psychology commit as a
fallacy.
They think that when you explain a
phenomenon,
you are justifying it.
So if you explain why men and women
might cheat on one another and
monogamous unions or you're offering a
scientific justification for cheating,
of course you're not.
Usually.
My rebuttal is the guy who studies
cancer,
an oncologist.
Does that mean he is for pancreatic
cancer?
He's justifying.
No,
he's just trying to explain why
pancreatic cancer happens.
Is that across
the board though?
I mean,
what if you try to explain why people
commit violent crimes or explain why
people steal things from stores?
That's a great question.
I think there are certain phenomena that
triggered that response more than others
and it's an open empirical question.
What's the quality of the phenomenon
that causes you to react that way or
not?
Let's say that it's most likely the
stronger person who seems to have the
privilege victimizing the weaker person.
Perhaps males versus females,
child abuse.
That's another one.
So actually feel.
Yeah,
right.
So the book,
so the book that got me into
evolutionary psychology,
I've,
I've mentioned this story before and
maybe not on the show.
It was my first semester as a doctoral
student at Cornell and the professor,
this was an advanced social psychology
course and the professor assigned the
book called homicide by two pioneers of
evolutionary psychology,
husband and wife team,
Margo Wilson and Martin Daly where the
book is about understanding patterns of
criminality via an evolutionary lens.
And one of the things in the book that
had struck me as so powerful was looking
at child abuse in the home and then the
demonstration that there's a very clear
evolutionary reason why that happens.
So let me ask you that.
I have.
We discussed this before in this show.
I don't think so.
I don't recall.
Can you guess at all?
Uh,
what is the number one greatest
predictor of there being a child abuse
in the home?
So for example,
you might say,
oh,
it's poverty.
You might say it's probably parents that
were abused as children.
No bigger than that.
Bigger than that,
much bigger.
That one factor is 100 fold greater
than.
So in other words,
typically when you say a what's called
an odds,
likelihood ratio one point two.
So you have a 20 percent greater chance
of getting cancer if you smoke.
So just having one point,
two greater odds is considered a big
number here.
I'm telling you a hundred fold greater.
So it's something that's almost never
seen in science.
What does having a step parent in the
home
now think again here,
another animal.
And to get the people who don't like 100
times greater.
This is this.
So actually it's now been called the
Cinderella effect because their Ela,
right?
She shows the,
the,
the evil step mother loves her two
biological daughters but hates the
stepdaughter Cinderella.
So that's okay.
Now think about with lions,
right?
In a lion pride,
you have a one or two dominant males who
who control and protect the pride and
who control sexual access to the
females.
There's constant testing of these males
by bands of young males who are looking
to take over and for awhile the resident
males went out and then eventually they
lose when they lose and they're either
killed or banished from the pride.
What's the first thing that the new
incoming bosses do?
They kill the boobies.
Boom.
They kill the babies.
What happens to the females that the
lionesses one,
they killed him.
They go into estrus,
right?
So instead of playing Barry White Music
and the violin to get them in the mood,
killed their children and they get in
the mood,
right?
Nature is brutal,
Well,
in the context of humans,
when you have a step parent who is not
biologically linked
to the child,
it simply increases the likelihood of
there being abuse right.
Now usually when you explain this,
what is the first thing that people say,
oh,
well I grew up with a stepfather and he
didn't do this to me.
You're an asshole or,
but,
but what are you saying?
That means it's okay to do it because
you're explaining it.
So look how they can flate explaining a
phenomenon with justifying the
phenomenon.
So I think rape,
child abuse and probably marital
infidelity are the three evolutionary
phenomena that when you explain using an
evolutionary lens,
people go completely Wacko.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
I mean,
it's something that it's.
You almost can't look at it.
It's right.
Forbidden in Islam village as per my
conversation with Sam Harris,
avoid that topic because you'll get too
much flack and that's dangerous.
Nothing should be forbidden.
So these scientists that wrote this
book,
whether they were examining rape and the
causes of rape,
what was the repercussions?
So I,
I was invited.
So around the Thorn Hill is at the
University of New Mexico and he's still
there.
Great Guy.
When when he invited me to his group,
invited me to give a talk at the
university,
him and I went out for a while and I
asked him that question.
He said at one point there had to be
constant police patrols because of all
the death threats and so on that he,
that he was getting nih.
I suspect that at this point in a
subsided,
this is 15,
16 years ago,
but when the book first came out,
it was dangerous to be around the
thornhill.
Well,
this is so bizarre where people that you
would think of the left,
right?
And as soon as you think of people that
are liberal and progressive,
you think these are nonviolent folks
that just want peace and happiness and
love.
But look what happened in Evergreen.
I mean this is what Bret Weinstein
talked about,
the threats,
and then all of a sudden you've got
vigilante patrols with tasers and
baseball bats and these are kids that
are running around trying to justify
using violence because someone doesn't
agree with their thoughts.
The whole idea of it was a day of
absence,
day of inclusion or does it day of
presence.
Right.
That was the idea was that white people
should stay home just once.
He was like,
that's fucking racist,
like you can't do that.
And He,
as he self describes as a deeply
progressive person in all my
conversations with him indicate that in
a huge way.
I mean he's just a really open minded,
progressive guy who he doesn't,
but he doesn't want racism against white
people to exist any more than he wants
it against black people.
But by the way,
I was.
So he came on my show too.
We had a great chat and second hiding.
Now interrupted.
Yeah.
No,
no problem.
Uh,
I,
I don't know if full hiding,
but he certainly not on campus,
but that's what he said.
He had to move his family.
Yeah.
Even know where.
But maybe I shouldn't say weird.
Yeah.
Well,
if you look at the comments section,
I wonder if the same thing happened when
he came on your show.
I was amazed at the animus that he was
being levied at him from people who were
saying,
Hey,
that guy is part of the problem.
He's a progressive who created the
monster that is now biting his ass,
and so let him let,
let let the snake and so on.
Charitable.
You didn't get.
No,
I didn't get that,
but I do understand why fools would
think because he's not real true.
Progressives like non ideologically
based progressive.
It's a good thing.
Exactly.
It's a good thing to note until the
think that,
hey man,
we should all be the same regardless of
your dreadlocks or a shaved head or if
you're white or black or.
It's a weird thing like,
like sexual preference.
We were talking about this before,
like if a man is only sexually attracted
to.
If he says I am sexually attractive,
I prefer white women.
You are a fucking racist.
But if you say,
I prefer black women.
Like Ooh,
spice it weird.
By the way,
this,
this cuts both ways.
So,
and I actually commented on this,
if you say I'm attracted to overweight
women,
you are objectifying and fetishizing are
corpulent bodies or you know,
that's what they'll say.
That's what they'll sell the
complainer's I should be happy.
Somebody likes.
If you say I don't like fat women
because I'm not,
then of course you're,
you're so.
Same thing with,
with black women,
right?
If you say,
look,
I just have a preference for black
women.
Oh yeah.
It's the old stereotype of the sexual
black woman with a beautiful behind.
You're objectifying us,
you're racist.
If you say,
you know,
I really don't like the,
the,
the body types of black women.
I prefer Asian women while you are
racist.
So all roads lead to you being an
asshole.
If you like them,
it's bad.
If you don't like them,
What if you just say you just enjoy
dating black women because of the way
the communicate.
Some race,
someone will probably accusing,
listen at correcting somebody for their
grammar.
If it's part of their dialect is racist.
Right?
So Ebonics.
I actually,
I was,
I was coming when we were coming here.
I was listening to a song by a see
Sierra Sierra general.
That is.
No,
she's a,
she's a hip hop singer and at one point
in one of the songs she goes,
there you is.
There you is.
So I told my wife,
I said,
you know,
it really pisses me off when they commit
these grammatical errors.
Yeah,
but isn't that an art thing?
I mean like I might say something
grammatically incorrect on stage,
everything.
It's funnier than saying it correctly.
Okay,
fine.
If you're doing it because it is part of
the sort of the contextualized shtick,
but isn't that what she's kind of doing
a rap song?
I don't know.
It's an open question.
Maybe it just rhymes better.
There you are.
Don't say there you,
but what if it's.
She's trying to run what rhymes with his
fizz fizz.
Yeah.
I don't sit in champagne.
Get my fears it.
Look over there.
There you is.
Should have been a rapper,
dude,
by the way,
you said.
You said that.
I'm saying that you were attracted to
black women.
Might be racist or not.
Did you hear the latest with the new,
um,
letter that was uncovered from Tupac
Shakur to a white chicks that.
No,
no.
That he broke up with her because she
was a white woman.
He broke up with Madonna.
Madonna.
Yeah.
She was annoying.
It was just trying to find an excuse.
That's a good way like that.
You can't ever change,
right?
You can't change the fact that you're
white.
That's a good move.
But imagine that the other way around.
Right.
If,
if,
if she had written him a letter saying,
hey,
dear Tupac,
I would have loved to continue this
relationship,
but given that you're a black guy,
her career would be over.
But him saying it to her,
he actually said,
he goes,
he said,
if you date me,
it appears as though you're an exciting
cool woman,
but if I continue to date you,
a lot of the people that made me who I
am would,
I would lose credit with the credit.
Taiwan,
she was thrown that posted correctly.
Probably still would have stuck around.
She's probably annoying.
She probably talks too much.
She probably talks about herself in the
third person,
like trump probably likes you.
Right?
I'm going to admit something now that's
going to come back to the hotline.
What?
Nineteen 85.
My cousin and I.
I shouldn't be saying this.
What did you do?
Drove to Toronto to see Madonna.
I would have done that.
Nineteen 85.
She was a fantastic performer.
She was a huge superstar.
Still kind of is.
I'm just joking around about being her,
her being annoying.
It's just a funny thing to say.
I was always big madonna fan when I was
younger.
I think,
you know,
is beautiful and interesting and bold
and mean.
You don't get that without a certain
amount of ego.
So to mock that ego is like,
well,
of course,
you know,
it's like,
that's who she was.
Yeah,
true.
You know,
and then I'm with Tupac is doing this.
I mean he's kind of like locked into the
identity politics of the 19 nineties.
I mean,
that's what,
what,
where he was,
you know,
is there,
is there a,
a person that you would love to have on
your show who is a artist that you
really love?
Um,
there's a lot of them.
There's not one.
There's one that's coming on my show.
I'll tell you who it is,
who,
uh,
I had announced this.
I hope that he doesn't somehow back out,
but I'll mention it doesn't matter if he
doesn't end up coming.
That's okay.
Have you,
do you know,
have you heard of Newton the way?
No,
no.
It's Ricky Martin.
No,
I'm kidding.
it's.
I live in Lavita logo.
Do you know,
do you know the group stylistics?
No.
The stylistics,
we're a old soul group that's part of a
genre called the philly sound.
So there's a type of black music that
late sixties,
early seventies that's is very soulful,
sexy soul type of music sites,
stylistics.
We're probably the epitome of that,
John.
Now.
This is a group that I grew up listening
to all the way back in Lebanon when I
was a kid and I've made contact with the
representatives of the lead singer and
he said that he will come on my show.
It's like,
oh,
exciting.
So all the people that I've had on my
show,
all of whom had been lovely and
accomplished people I think,
and I hope I'm not being insulting to
anybody.
I don't think I'm as excited to be
speaking to anyone which shows,
by the way,
the power of music,
right?
As much as I am in speaking to this
gentleman.
Uh,
you know,
who in this area go there.
That's actually not the singer,
a set of bare chest under a suit coat.
That's the guy that's rustled Thompkins
Jr.
Wow.
Fro strong.
He's got What's called the falsetto
voice.
She goes very,
very high with his voice.
You are
very good.
And I've heard that song.
Isn't it Funny how like people used to
dance and move back then everyone waS
like synchronized and there was like a
thing they used to do together.
I know that doesn't really happen
anymore.
I wonder what happened where people
decided that synchronized singing like
five men together stage.
It's not cool anymore.
Well,
you do Have boy bands.
You have backstreet boys or men is men.
Yeah.
These are men.
These are.
This is five men moving their arms and
singing in synchronicity while people
dance slowly,
which no one does anymore.
No one dances like that anymore.
Who fucks things like that anymore?
Who fucked dance that dances like that
anymore?
It's weird,
right?
I know someone needs to bring back the
soul,
train it in 2001.
When we lived in southern California,
I had the crazy idea of calling the
representatives of the stylistics to see
how much it would cost to hire them for
private concert.
Somehow I thought that a professor had
enough of a salary.
The higher the stylistics for a private
concert.
How many people apparently,
you know,
I just had this fantasy that,
wouldn't it be amazing to invite people
to apparently a much poorer than I think
I am?
Yeah.
I think it's five dudes.
It was actually.
I can't remember the exact amount,
but it was something in the order.
this is 15,
16 years ago it was,
I can't remember.
Maybe half a million dollars.
The cost of flying them in their fee,
so I went to uc irvine was not paying me
enough.
I can't remember the exact number,
but it was much more than I could
afford.
Wow.
What were you hoping for?
Like 10 grand,
50 thouSand,
50,000 you were hoping for?
Yeah,
that would seem like reasonable.
That's like,
you know,
I thought I had joe rogan money,
but I only have mere professor money
that's even 50,000.
It's like I wouldn't spend that much
money.
It's christ.
If you could.
What's your favorite group?
It's probably metallica.
Metallica.
I love me some metallic,
especially when I'm working out and
shit.
I mean you did tell me prior to us
starting how much you love share.
you didn't say these tramps and thieves.
That's what town.
So who's your favorite?
I'm not have a favorite.
give me really don't led zepplin.
Okay.
Led zepplin you found out they steal
music.
Stairway to heaven story.
I'd heard that hurts pretty bad,
but then they get almond brothers.
They got exonerated as they paid off
some fucking.
Is that true?
Do you know how much money they would
have to give back?
How much the record
companies would have to give back?
But it was established and it was
stolen.
Like in terms of the.
You want to play it?
You want to play here?
Here.
Let's play it.
So we could just.
Can we do it or would they were they?
Fuck us.
Youtube fargo's alright.
So we'll,
we'll do this and it won't be on youtube
to the people listening right now on
youtube.
You're not going to hear shit,
but this is what we'll do.
We will synchronize.
Jamie will tell you what this is and you
can synchronize it doesn't even work
like that.
Can you open up to youtube windows?
I'll put up the.
I can put the video in the corner so you
can see what we're up a 56 second video
called led up verse spirit stairway to
heaven comparison.
So we'll have to kind of talk a little
bit of it.
Otherwise,
the people that are listening to this
live streaming,
you're going to get this,
it's just going to be blank,
dead air.
So this is the originAl song.
This is not the led zeppelIn version.
This is the song that lead's up.
Been fucking ripped off exactly.
Like dude is 100 percent.
It's not like 80 percent or 70 percent.
That's 100 percent.
They stole this.
This band opened for them.
Oh,
it's only one of many.
I mean there's a lot of influences that
they had from old blues songs that they
added to some of their songs,
which is more forgivable,
almost a kin to what they do today with
rap music,
with sampling,
which I don't have any problem with it
all.
I mean I think it kind of enhances it
and makes you think about the old song.
But this is agregious.
So what was their position?
It just happened by fluke that we came
up with the same notes,
just hired the best lawyers.
They got themselves some jews.
Is that,
is that nsma?
That's awesome.
At being lawyers.
So here,
did you play the okay as both of them.
Okay.
We'll play the play the second part of
the first one.
So the first one is stairway to heaven.
Where does it go?
There's a better version of it.
Oh,
that's the compare it.
Okay.
Well let's
go back to it.
See if you can.
What?
We'll see.
Which one is a.
Okay,
here we go.
This is.
This is the California bands psychedelic
band spirit.
This is a taurus.
This is not sound.
Now.
This is different.
Is that.
That's not it.
The taurus is the sound you're listening
to right now.
Hold on a second.
It changes.
Hold on a second here.
Okay.
Here.
This part.
Yeah.
okay.
The court.
That's not even a good question.
There's a better system.
That riff is the part that's in
question.
That's it.
Yeah.
Maybe it was one of the other songs.
Yeah,
there's other songs.
Okay.
So not,
not,
not.
Not withstanding the potential for them
having done some unsavory things.
They're pretty bad ass.
You couldn't.
You wouldn't spend $50,000.
You have as your guest of honor,
the godfather at your house and you say,
ladies and gentlemen,
let's going.
He's a closet led zeppelin fan.
I get to.
He's trying to.
do we try to.
First of all,
you know how much money you'd have to
pay.
Like you always hear about these guys,
like I'm in the middle east,
some arabic brianna to go over there and
perform.
I think a million is like a bargain.
Yeah.
Like what didn't beyonce go and do some
crazy concert for new year's and dubai
for somebody for like 5 million bucks or
something.
Yeah.
That's pays to be super famous I guess.
What do you think of Janet Jackson
marrying some oil sha?
She's full on burka.
Burka,
yeah.
Well some of those videos need to be
expunged from our collective memory.
When she pulled the tid out at the
superbowl,
jay z and kanye paid $6,000,000 to
perform in dubai,
which is hilarious.
This.
Is there a place that you would be
invited for a very large sum of money
that you would refuse because you
disagree politically or ideologically
would whatever that person was inviting
you stands for sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
Certainly they didn't.
They didn't know they were bought for
some price.
Well,
it's a little bit different what they do
because they would go over there and
they,
I guess they would know like what their
material would be,
you know,
like if they went over there to perform
99 problems like jay z's,
his lyrics are out there,
you know,
they say like,
hey,
we would like you going to give you 6
million bucks.
We want you to sing 99 problems and all
these different songs.
The lyrics are clearly established.
Right.
But if someone like me went over there
and did comedy,
like,
oh,
who was it?
Was it who?
One of the guests I had in the past?
Um,
house parks,
I think it was house parks that went
over to dubai and he,
he had did a bit and he was told by one
of the people in the audience that he
was going to be arrested because he
referred to one of the royal family by
the wrong name.
Call them sir instead of your highness.
And so they were going to arrest him.
Wow.
But then some other member of the royal
family stepped in and stopped it because
they said no,
he was respectful and he just didn't
understand the traditional protocol,
but they were ready to lock him up in a
fucking cage because he used the wrong
term.
Not even in a disrespectful manner.
Right?
Yeah.
Just just called him sir.
You know?
Yeah.
Like that's not the place that I'm
going.
I'm,
I'm just,
I'm not interested in any place.
Look man,
there's a real problem with Canada right
now and know.
I know.
You know what happened in vancouver.
We're a comic.
Was heckled by these lesbians.
Yes.
And shit all over them.
And then they sued him and won because
he had done something to violate their
human rights because they were heckling,
not just him,
but people before him.
They were disrupting a live performance.
So do you think
this trend of famous comics refusing to
perform at universities is only going to
continue to increase or again,
have we reached the maximum and now
there's going to be blow back?
Because I know jerry seinfeld doesn't do
it.
Chris rock doesn't do it right.
I haven't done it since 2003,
maybe it was the last time I did a show
it as a cost center set.
Yeah.
I don't think they have enough life
experience.
You know,
I like to talk to people that have
lived.
When I,
when I talked to people I want to talk
to someone who has had affairs,
love affairs and uh,
has,
had jobs and been fired,
has had education and as I want someone
with life experience,
not there's anything wrong with being 18
or whatever,
19,
but I want someone who's got some living
under their belt so they know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
Right?
I don't want to have to explain
everything I don't want.
I did a concert once,
a concert,
but did a show once in the university
and I was talking about something sexual
and I saw this bewildered,
looks in the audience.
How many people are virgins?
I go,
don't,
don't even raise your hand because I
don't incriminate you.
I go,
just blink real fast.
And they started laughing,
but it got real uncomfortable.
I go,
would you again?
I'm not gonna even look at you.
I go,
I'm going to look at the sky.
Would you say that I would be out of
line if I said 10 percent of you were
virgins and the place went?
They went,
no,
that's good.
It's probably about right.
People like yelling.
I'm like,
that's crazy.
Ten percent of you are virgins.
That's like if there's 200 people,
each one of you are fucking virgin is
really.
That's a lot of people and it's probably
more than that.
They're probably being modest or not
being honest about it.
I just,
it's not nothing wrong with being
college obviously,
but as far as like where I want to
perform,
I don't have a lot of,
you know,
if I have a day,
there's 24 hours in that day.
I don't have a lot of hours to perform
at night.
If I'm performing at night,
I get a couple of hours.
you know,
I'd like,
I like doing actual comedy,
like doing what I do and then one of the
things about comedy is it's,
it's different than any other art form
in that.
Like say if you go to see music,
like you know what you're going to go
see,
you don't usually just say,
oh,
live music.
Like,
well,
let's hope that it's something I'm
interested in.
You know,
we're going to see jay z followed by
Johnny Cash followed by loretta lynn.
No,
It's not going to be that way.
You're gonna go to a rock and roll club.
You go to the viper room,
most likely gonna hear some rock and
roll and he'd go to a country western
bar.
You know,
you get to see that.
I think with standup comedy,
people get upset if you're not doing
like what appeals to them and their
sensibility.
So I like to go to nightclubs.
That's where I like,
I like,
I don't even do corporate gigs.
I get a lot of offers to do these
corporate gigs and they'll,
they'll pay you a lot of money.
There'll be to tame the audience.
They won't know.
It's not a,
it's not a real comedy show.
It's like you guys are paying.
It's like your gad sad paying 50 grand
to have these guys singing your
backyard.
Some weird ego thing,
right?
I saw my friend dana white,
who is the.
He's head of the ufc.
He had a birthday party years back and
stone temple pilots played for that dude
died of an overdose.
RIght.
And man,
nobody was fucking paying attention.
It was weird.
Stone temple pilots mean they kinda got
everybody to pay attention.
Got everybody moved towards the stage,
but people a didn't know to expect stone
temple pilots who was a big surprise and
when I even introduced them,
when I introduce stone temple pilots,
people didn't even think that it was
really going to be stone temple pilots.
Like I said,
happy birthday to dana,
thanked him for everything and then I
said,
and I'm going to blow your mind right
now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
stone temple pilots,
and they came out and it was really
stone temple pilots.
They went hard.
They did there.
It was really,
really impressive stuff because they did
their full on concert,
like a 100 percent all out.
it was intense.
It was really amazing,
but it wasn't a lot of people paying
attention.
And while I was,
while I was sitting there watching it,
I was like,
you know what?
Yeah,
never again.
I'm never doing.
I mean I'd already decided I wasn't
going to do it.
I wasn't going to do that anyway,
but I remember
that you said,
I think in our first chat several years
ago,
which has resonated and stuck with me,
you were comparing your career as a
standup comic or in fighting to the
truth that comes in science,
that you're comparing that to acting,
which is very ephemera and fuzzy and you
were saying basically,
look,
when you're a scientist,
you have to present stuff and it's
either right or wrong and people are
going to judge you and you analogized it
to comedy.
You get up in front of a crowd,
you either know you're either funny or
you're going to bomb.
You get up to fight.
You either are ready or are you going to
get pummeled.
And I thought that was a really good
analogy because there's truth and
honesty in that,
right?
There is no way to wing it.
As a comic.
You get up and you better be funny,
right?
Yeah,
but it's very subjective,
like one thing to make might make you
laugh is different.
Someone might think is terrible.
I mean there's a lot of people that are
fans of certain comedians that other
people think or how awful it just like
music,
you know,
there's certain types of.
It's all subjective.
It's,
it's like when you consider art,
what's really like fighting even it's
like who's not necessarily even who's
necessarily better.
SometImes it's like what happened in the
moment.
Sometimes dudes collide heads and it
changes the course of a fight and it's
not because of skill.
It's because in the moment something
happened chaotic or someone got poked in
the eye and they couldn't see well,
and then they got knocked out.
Are they the worst fighter?
Not necessarily.
It's like sometimes there's a.
There's all sorts of unpredictable
variables that come into place.
Here's a guy that I recently discovered.
He's an italian comedian Who had an hbo
special.
I thought,
sebastian sebastian maniscalco.
He's a buddy of mine.
He's been on the podcast.
No kidding.
Hilarious.
I,
I live it.
Usually when I watch standup comics,
I mean,
I'll laugh a bit.
I think this is funny that,
but that guy in that
show,
I've probably watched shows on showtime.
Showtime.
Yeah.
I literally could not stop laughing
because somehow his humor very much
resonated with some of our sort of
middle eastern italian.
Yeah.
And I just get so gravitate towards him
just this guy's fantastic.
He really is.
He's a great guy too.
He's,
he's like,
nobody hates that guy.
Like that guy is loved in the comedy
community,
but does he,
is he.
Has he been known for a long.
He's been doing it for a long time and
he's an interesting case because when he
first started out he wasn't doing that
good,
you know,
he had a really work hard at it to
become who he is,
but he stuck with it and chipped away at
it and got better and better and better.
And I didn't see him for a long time
because I had taken mY hiatus from the
comedy store and um,
I saw him on showtime when I wasn't at
the comedy store anymore.
And I thought it was so fucking funny.
I met,
I remember tweeting at them.
Then I got ahold of him,
I said,
dude,
that was amazing.
It's so good.
And I had heard that he was doing really
well,
but I hadn't seen him perform and it was
probably like six years,
five or six years at least.
And um,
he just had gotten so much better.
That's an eighth right.
You agree that much of our humor.
I mean,
it's not something that you could teach
and a workshop.
Right?
How to be funny one.
Oh,
one.
right.
It's just,
you either have that delivery,
you know,
how to.
I would say you have an ember.
okay.
And you,
if your lungs,
you have an ember,
you could become really funny.
But I've met a lot of people that sucked
in the beginning and they just got
really good.
They because they really worked hard at
it.
And here's the most important thing,
and this is like,
it's,
this relates to what we've been talking
about,
being objective about the actual root
cause of why people like you or don't
like you try to figure out what,
what it is about what you're doing that
people don't like and correct it.
Right.
Get better,
improve,
and the onlY way to improve is not blame
the audience.
Oh,
you're a bunch of sTupid,
but people do do that.
And the people that do make those
excuses and don't instead look
internally,
you know,
like sometimes you can have a bad side
and you got to say,
well,
you know what man,
I fucked that up.
I jusT wasn't tuned in.
I gotta I gotta I gotta readjust.
I got,
you know,
maybe I was sick that day and there's
always reasons necessarily,
um,
not,
not necessarily excuses rather,
but you got to examine those
uncomfortable moments and some people
excuse themselves by that by saying that
audience sucked or you know,
these people are assholes or you know,
these people are stupid.
There's a bunch of excuses that people
make and it's super critical that you
don't do that.
You've got to look at data,
look at the whole thing.
Do you juke in terms of actionable
feedback?
Do you look for it from other
professional comics because you trust
their opinions more?
Or are you looking for the civilians in
the audience to give you that feedback?
What?
Which one is more actionable from your
perspective as you're trying to improve
your craft is very problematic to play
for the comedians because comedians like
weird shit,
like we might like something completely
obscure that we don't see common,
you know,
but an audience might not be laughing
and you might hear one comment in the
back of their own fucking ridiculous and
the audience doesn't think it's funny
and then there's a trap that the
comedians will fall into with a start
playing for their peers specifically.
There's a bunch of guys that have,
I don't want to call anybody out,
but there's people that have ruined
their career because they essentially
became the comic place to the back of
the room and the audience didn't think
they were funny and essentially they're
making fun of people who try to be funny
and instead exonerating themselves for
many real pressure to be funny because
hey,
I'm here to make comics laugh.
I'm a comic's comic.
Right?
Well,
the real comics are comics comp,
like dave chappelle's a comic's comic,
but he kills the audience too because
he's real.
He's got the full package where there's
a lot of comics that bomb in front of
the audience,
but you'll have 20 guys in the back of
the room that think it's cool to chuckle
at obscure references and very bizarre
words that get used in some sort of
strange weather would be sort of like
that,
right.
Because he,
just to follow his references takes you
like a flow chart of 20 pages long.
Right.
I talked to norm mcdonald about him
once.
It was really funny.
It was.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
he's not really that smart.
Has really know those words.
Like a one.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
He just,
he just finds out words that people
don't know and he uses them and uh,
people laugh even though they don't know
what he's talking about.
So someone played a joke on him once
where they use some reference.
They use some refereNce on Dennis Miller
that they made up.
oh,
it was dom.
I rera used a reference on Dennis Miller
that he's fade up and dennis started
laughing at it even though it wasn't
real because it was like something that
you had to be like,
cool to know tom to remember that door.
But he was like his,
like,
he goes,
I fucked him with his own thing.
I tricked him with his own trick.
I,
he just used a reference that isn't real
and he just can't,
you
know,
because people don't like to be on the
outside.
Like people don't like to say what the
fuck does that mean?
I'm a big fan of saying what does that
mean?
Yeah.
Because I look,
I've had 900 plus podcast with 700
people wave fucking smarter than me.
So like I have to say,
I don't knoW what that means.
Like you got to be mean.
But there's a weird thing where people
don't like to,
they equate not having information with
somehow and they're being less
intelligent,
which is a really bizarre thing because
like,
it's okay if you're talking to someone
about something that you couldn't
possibly have data on,
like a,
you know,
whatever.
A video game,
right,
that you don't play,
like what's it about?
Like how's it go?
Like that's okay,
that's fine,
but as soon as it's something about like
some sort of cultural reference or
perhaps a book that maybe you should
have initiatives you to admit that you
don't know.
That's a weird damn.
You know,
it's a weird thing to be somehow or
another,
you feel diminished by information or a
lack of it.
It's so funny that you say this because
in my classes students will oftentimes
ask me a question and that has me
stumped and I will usually answer it.
You know what?
I actually don't know the answer.
Could you send me an email so I could
look it up?
That's beautiful.
And they are really impressed by that.
Honesty Was impressive.
Yeah.
So I hear you.
It's about the military I guess.
But on the other hand,
when I know something,
I come out with the bravado of I know my
shit,
right?
So have the,
have the humility to know what you know
and what you don't know as the old
saying says,
you know,
well you have um,
the,
that,
what you would say bravado.
It's like a pride of hard work.
I mean you've accumulated a massive
amount of knowledge of from seeking this
knowledge and studying very hard.
So it's something that you should be
proud of,
but it's not something that you look at.
Like when you're proud of it,
you're not diminishing other people that
don't have that information.
You're just saying like,
this is what I know to be true and this
is a fact.
This is undeniable.
But that's a beautiful thing that you
could also say,
I don't know about something that you
don't know,
right?
That will give the people that are
listening,
that will give them so much more of a
sense of respect for you venture than
horse shooting around and pretending
that's such a weird thing that people
do.
And by the way,
the media,
oftentimes they want you to weigh in on
things as a scientist,
which you don't feel that your area of
expertise would allow you to and they
get frustrated because then they feel as
though you're equivocating.
But I said,
look,
I'm sorry,
but I'm not willing to make that
statement.
Would that level of certainty,
but they want it because that's what the
headline has to say.
And then they get frustrated that you're
tippy toeing,
but I'm just being humble about what is
true and what I don't think I'm
knowledgeable enough to say it's true.
Yeah.
I've had people get upset at me about.
I'm talking about a upcoming martial
arts fights because a,
I don't give predictions.
I very,
very,
very rarely give predictions unless
there's some gross mismatch.
It really shouldn't be happening in the
first place because you really have no
idea what's going to happen.
There's a high likelihood that something
might happen.
If I look at the way one guy moves
versus another guy moves and I go into
my database of experiences of seeing a
lot of live competition and knowing what
one person is capable of,
I can make.
I can make a statement with reasonable
certainty,
but I don't know if they were injured in
training.
I don't know if they come into the fight
sick.
I don't know if they're breaking up with
their girlfriend.
I don't know if they got staph infection
two weeks before the fight and run ended
up biotics.
There's so many variables.
I don't know if they might get
headbutted like we've talked about
earlier or they might have an injury
like in the middle of the fight,
like something goes wrong and their knee
blows out.
There's so many variables.
Has the thing between the boxer and the
mma guy happened yet?
See,
thIs is.
I love when someone.
I know.
I love that though.
I know I'm not.
I'm not criticizing you,
but I love when someone is so far
removed,
but they're still aware of something
that's like a big cultural event.
No,
it takes place August 26th.
I think even I,
I'm an unbelievable novice when it comes
to this stuff.
I think I could make a prediction here
in front of your huge podcast that the
mma guys going to get trashed.
Correct.
Um,
I would imagine that most likely he is
going to lose a boxing match to the
boxer that has every little.
What's the point of this fight?
Just for,
for my name thIng,
if you wanted to see a figure skater
play hockey against wayne gretzky.
okay.
So why would the mma guy put himself up
for that potential humiliation,
money,
dollar dollar bills.
Y'all been on your show?
No,
he has not.
I fucked up.
I should have had them on back before he
blew up.
He's too big now.
I refer to him as a conrad last time or
something.
Right?
Something like that.
His name's connor.
Connor mcgregor.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
uh,
he's a,
a real meteoric,
a entity and like the most media or can
all of combat sports.
He became so famous so quick and for
[inaudible],
he's a,
he's a real unicorn in a lot of ways.
Get so many different things going for
him.
Handsome guy,
brutal knockout artists,
predicts outcomes and pulls them off
and,
and uh,
has been incredibly successful in a
short period of time.
One,
two world titles in two different weight
classes and is arguably the greatest
trash talker ever.
He trashed talks better than anybody
because that right there is actually a
big thing that's going on today,
right?
The press conference or actually I'm
reading the thing,
they're scalping tickets outside of it
for 40 bucks right now to my 40.
It's a free.
It was free.
Oh,
my nephew is probably all over that
stuff,
right?
Probably.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's um,
it's the press conference itself will be
a show because this guy is so good at
getting people riled up and talk and
shit.
And that's half the fun.
Like I was too young to appreciate the
mohammed ali days,
but I would imagine that when muhammad
ali was challenging sonny liston,
like half of the fun was mohammed ali
talk and shit.
Like,
this guy's crazy.
That's exactly the mechanism When I take
on some random person online and I just
have fun with it.
Sometimes people miss understand this to
be.
I'm getting pissed.
I'm just happy.
I'm just doing bantering.
I'm usually doing this with a smile on
my face,
but they think of it as though I'm.
But I'm just trash talking about.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing,
man.
It's like engaging with people you don't
know.
Like sometimes that person's insane and
then they'll make it a career to go
after god sat all day long.
It's like
it's interacting with people in text
form is very problematic.
Right?
It's just like a lot of issues.
You don't,
you don't get social cues.
You can adjust.
You can't,
you know,
like in our conversation we're kind of
going back and forth and you say
something and I react to it and we laugh
and we see eaCh other.
all that's missing.
When you're writing things,
you know,
especially if someone like writes a blog
about you.
If somebody listens to what you've said
on this podcast and they write a blog
about you defining you,
he Is a man that does this.
His whole career is this and you read
it.
Like sam harris was just explaining
something to me that someone did about
him and uh,
I read it and I was like,
wow,
this is such a weird way to describe and
interact with the person that you've
never even met credible to write a one
sided thing where you don't even know
the guy.
You don't really know him,
like really know him.
Like,
you know,
you've,
you've seen some videos,
maybe the excuse me to interrupt and
that you would muster such animus
towards a person that you haven't met.
Right?
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I'm fortunate enough to not have too
many of these haters and trolls,
but there is one or two guys that have
come to my attention that it seems as
though they spend 90 percent of their
day doing.
He trashed stuff about me and you think,
what could it be that I could so trigger
in them that they would construe it as a
valuable use of their time to take on
someone whom they've never even met.
But somehow they're pissed at you and
they think it's a worthwhile cause to
trash talk you all that.
Well,
that's a weird thing,
like even if they have a valid point,
there becomes some sort of weird
symbiotic slash parasitic relationship
with the person that you're criticized,
like you are inexorably connected to
them.
They are your enemy.
You think about them all the time and by
virtue that you become part of them or
they become part of you.
That's the weird thing about thinking,
right?
like when you're on stage and you are
giving a lecture,
one of the more amazing things that
happens when someone is on stage talking
about something is you allow them to
kind of think for you in the sense that
when you are,
and that's one of the reasons why it's
so important to be articulate and so
important to be very aware of what
you're going to say in advance.
the point where it comes out smoothly
and there's good entertainment value to
it,
is that it's pleasing to listen to it
for you.
You're aware of how annoying certain
speech patterns can be and you avoid
those.
you're aware of how compelling are the
speech patterns can be new.
Embrace those and so it makes it
pleasing for the person to listen to so
they can just sit back and listen to you
talk about evolutionary psychology.
Whereas when a person sucks at it,
it's like grading.
It's painful.
It gets in your head.
You're not connected with them,
you're not allowing them to think about
for you.
Right.
There's,
there's,
that happens with comedy too,
like when someone is really good,
like you see it like a great comic,
like a louis c care,
someone like that.
when he's on stage and he's,
he's really in the groove.
You're kind of allowing him to think for
you.
You're like letting him take the reins
of your imagination and your mind and
your visualization.
But boy,
it must be a tough job because I always
think,
what if you just had a fight with your
wife?
I've had that before piss right?
But in 10 minutes I don't give a shit
about your fight.
You have to perform.
Right.
What kind of comedy you have?
Like if you're sam kennison,
it's probably better because your ankle
onstage,
you fuck.
Like he would go onstage probably angry,
pumped.
I mean,
it really depends on what you're trying
to do and it also depends on like what
the fight was about whether or not you
were wrong or she was wrong.
I would be way better off going onstage
if someone wronged me versus if I'm
wrong.
Deb,
you have I wrong.
Someone.
Yeah.
that's intrusive.
Thoughts in your head.
Okay.
Yeah.
Remorse.
Just in,
in reexamining your own behavior
patterns and finding fault.
Numb and just fine.
That's,
that's the last thing I ever want to do
is treat someone wrong and then go on
stage.
But if someone treated me like shit and
then went on stage,
I probably feel exonerated.
You know,
I'd feel like I'd feel I'd probably be
energized,
you know?
Interesting.
Very interesting.
I'm not sure what,
how much time we have left.
We're done.
It's too.
We did three hours.
Is crazy.
Unbelievable.
Next time we'll talk about,
because you mentioned red.
I guess it's related to regret.
Yeah.
We'll talk about the pSychology of
regret.
Psychology of regret.
Old.
Smart.
All right.
Always a pleasure,
my friend.
Thank you.
Really,
really enjoyed this conversation.
Thank you so much.
And tell everybody how to get ahold of
your podcasts,
get ahold of your youtube vIdeos
earlier.
Right?
So,
uh,
if you want to follow me on twitter at
gad,
gad s a d,
if you want to follow me on my youtube
channel,
just enter gad,
saad,
or the sad,
sad truth.
See,
assume folks back tomorrow with maynard.
Tina from tool puts a firm
I wasn't sure.